(CYMBAL ROLLS)
(DRAMATIC MUSIC PLAYING)
(MUSIC BUILDS)
# PINKFONG: Baby Murloc
# Baby murloc
# Mrgl, mrgl, mrgl, mrgl
Mrgl, mrgl, mrgl, mrgl
# Baby murloc
# Baby murky
# Traveller murloc
Mrgl, mrgl, mrgl, mrgl
# Finley Mrrgleton
# Cleaner murloc
Mrgl, mrgl, mrgl, mrgl
# Mrmr glmr
# Chef murloc
Mrgl, mrgl, mrgl, mrgl
# Captain cookie
# King murloc
Mrgl, mrgl, mrgl, mrgl
# Mrgl mrgl
(GIGGLING)
# Let's go hunt
Mrgl, mrgl, mrgl, mrgl
# Let's go hunt!
(MUSIC BUILDS)
Hmm?
(BOING)
# Run away
# Run away!
# Safe at last
# Safe at last, phew!
# It's the end
Mrgl, mrgl, mrgl, mrgl
# It's the end!
# INSTRUMENTAL MUSIC
Candy, Candy,
Can - dy
And there's no one here.
I'm alone.
But ...
we can't do candy this time
because things are different.
But we are here and I am Darren
and I'm so excited
to spend the stay with you.
Thank you, thank you,
Thank you all
for sharing your time with us.
Wherever you are watching from,
I hope that you and yours
are safe and healthy
because we have a
wonderful show planned.
I am thrilled
to be back with you.
Thrilled,
do you hear me saying this?
It's Darren, I'm always
thrilled.
Thank you all for enjoying
what I have brought to
Community Night
over the years.
You are all very kind.
It means the world to me.
Tonight, just think of me as...
the human equivalent of
comfort food.
I am meatloaf in a suit
or if you're vegan I am
tofu with a pocket handkerchief.
Either way,
I am so looking
forward to today.
When Blizzard reached out to me
about doing this,
I thought about the line
at the end of Honor and Glory.
Hey...
I got the thing, here it is.
You know when Reinhart says
"I have been called,
I must answer, always".
I thought about
Reinhart's kindness
and his devotion,
his sense of
being there for others.
That line,
that line errr,
it's very important line to me.
It resonates with me,
it's a powerful line.
Is it my favorite
Rhinehart line? No!
People ask a lot of the cast,
what's your favorite line?
(REPEATS)
what's your favorite ...
character...
and I've never said what mine
is. I've never said it.
It's something
I've struggled with,
I've put a lot of
thought into it
and then it hit me.
For me...
there is no favorite line.
There is only
Overwatch.
There is only Warcraft.
There is only Hearthstone,
Diablo,
StarCraft,
Heroes of the Storm.
These are worlds
and characters
that I want to spend time with,
that I want to
immerse myself in.
Every time I get to
go into the recording booth.
become one of my now
75 Blizzard characters.
How did that happen?
That's my favorite time.
That's what I do to hopefully
give you your favorite moment.
It's a little bit of joy,
a little bit of madness,
a little bit of whimsy.
But at the heart of it,
if you think about it,
that's Blizzard.
That's this community.
That creative spark
that will inspire
outrageous cosplay,
beautiful art,
wonderful performances.
Those worlds, those characters.
Hey, in Warcraft,
they put a giant sword
into a planet.
In Overwatch, there was a
gorilla scientist from the moon
and there's a small
hamster that somehow
knows how to operate
heavy machinery.
And we love it.
That's this community to me.
That's what today is about.
All the cosplayers, the artists,
the short film makers,
the singers, the musicians,
getting their crazy, delicious,
delightful, Goshallheck, "Wow!"
moment.
Sharing their skill
and their passion.
So that you go
"How do they do that?"
Why did they do that?
Can I do that?
Of course you can!
It's that creative spark.
That will be shared by everyone
you're going to see tonight.
So even in this time of
distance,
our community
creates things that
give us connection.
It's that spirit
that makes me so thrilled to see
what everyone
has in store for us.
It will be
a little bit of joy,
a little bit of madness,
a little bit of whimsy
and also, stick around for
the end because we're gonna
bring on a special guest
to help me announce
Best in Show Cosplay Award.
And now,
grab your favorite beverage
could be iced tea,
could be moon berry juice.
Sit back, relax,
because we are about to start.
And we going to start
with a segment you'll be seeing
throughout the program
aptly named Talent Spotlight.
We just started and
already I am so happy.
What a surprise, it's me.
I am always blown away by
what everyone has to offer.
And there will be more talent
spotlights
throughout the program.
But right now,
We are going to get right into
what you have
all been waiting for...
the Cosplay.
Our community does some of
the best cosplay out there
and we are so excited to
showcase it here for you.
In the cosplay contest,
the entrants were judged on:
originality,
design,
creativity, and execution.
For our first cosplay category,
no one does character, armor,
weapons better than Blizzard.
And this year, we're ahh
doing something
a little different
to introduce
some of those contest finalists.
We're shining a light on the
community members from each
of the six blizzard franchises,
who are making a difference
within their communities
by bringing people together
through gaming.
To start us off here is
Vitor Ravnus Silveira.
Hi there, my name is
Vitor Silveira.
I'm also known as Ravnus or Rav
and I'm from Brazil.
For those who don't know,
I am the creator of a project
called Ecopoint Brazil.
This project has been
a lifesaver for me
and for some members
of the community.
We've been able to connect
in a whole different way.
We've been doing,
like, a lot of work
for the environment
planting, doing reforesting,
cleaning.
I want to thank everyone for
helping me and allowing me
to make this come true.
Overwatch was a
life changer for me.
I loved the universe,
I loved ...
the characters,
they are amazing, I loved
the soundtrack, I loved
the gameplay.
I love how the game works
and the lore ... was that
allowed me to create
the project Ecopoint so...
That changed my life forever.
And now ... here are
the finalists and winner
for this year's cosplay and
weapons and armor category.
# UPBEAT MUSIC
Another amazing spotlight.
And congratulations
to all the finalists
of the weapons and armor
cosplay category.
The winner on hire a cosplay
is now qualified for the best
in-show cosplay award
at the end of the program.
Moving on...
Storytelling is what really
captures our attention
and keeps bringing us back
to the worlds and realms of
Blizzard.
And this community, you guys,
you're so great because
you take those stories
and you make them your own.
So now, let's take a look
at the third place finalist
for Digital Storytelling.
# MUSIC IN CRESCENDO
MARCHING STEPS
It's over, Sylvanus.
Stop this bloodshed.
Jeyna.
If Silvanus responds with
terms that are acceptable to me,
peace is upon us.
No one is better suited to
discuss the matter further.
I trust in Genn Greymaine.
There you are, a Lions dog.
DOG PANTING
The horde is now at
open war with the alliance.
Has Stormwind finally
come out to play?
DOG PANTING
I have no time for games.
Not while I reign.
This war will not end
until we stand victorious.
Such a feeble mind.
No!
Do not keep me waiting.
You have no idea
what you're up against.
My victory was inevitable.
The forsaken will
never stop fighting.
Ugh! Fool!
I don't do bouncy.
DOG WHIMPERS
Enough of your insolence.
Look up and around you.
This is war.
Time is a luxury
we do not possess.
DOG BARKS
#HEAVY DRUMMING MUSIC
Nathanos
give me a moment.
#DRAMATIC BONE MUSIC
Interesting.
You truly have the
stomach for war.
You, it seems have
a genuine taste for it.
I require the services
of one whom I can trust.
One to witness true power.
BONES FALLING
For you!
BONE NOISES
This will be a
convenient partnership.
DOG WHINES
I will have need of you.
For the Horde!
Wow! Well, I'm embarrassed.
DARREN: And cue 1,342. Go!
Lee, camera four.
I want a slow pan in on the
host.
A DePaul mover, number seven.
No, Lee that's a DePaul move
number six.
Are we not paying attention?
Slowly.
Slow! Slowly, Lee!
Slowly, Lee!
O aye aye!
OK, let's go to camera three.
Epp! That's not working.
Hi! Since no one is here,
I thought I'd take...
RADIO: Someone tell Darren
there's no camera there.
I've gone mad with power.
(MAD LAUGH)
Now, we're gonna
move right along
to the next cosplay category,
Blizzard character.
Let's get to know Scott Levy,
AKA - Bites!
As he helps to
introduce the finalists
OK Lee, let's go!
Cue Number One.
Back to one!
-RADIO: Nobody tell Darren.
-Brilliant
Lee, this is great.
Keep going! Keep going!
Keep going!
You went too far Lee! O God!
Hey I'm Scott Levy,
also known as Hearthstone
Innkeeper Bites,
and I'm in Phoenix Arizona.
Over the years I've gotten
a reputation of
hosting over-the-top events.
And for me
first these gatherings became
a kind of creative outlet.
As someone who gets lots of joy
for hosting live events,
it's been an
especially difficult year.
It hasn't stopped me connecting
with my Hearthstone family.
Being restricted
to online events
has pushed me to create
some unique tournaments
like Battle Blitz and
Battle Grind.
I've gotten to the point now
where I've mentored
other innkeepers
and provide them with
tools and resources
and training to help
make their events better.
I run some charity events and
and created resources online
for everyone to use
and giving back to the community
means a lot to me.
One of the things that I miss
the most of course is Blizzcon.
I miss all the people
and the live tournaments
and the spectacle of it all
and I even miss the
2 1/2 hours it takes
of glue and make up and paint
to transform me into
The Innkeeper.
And as much work as it is
to transform me into this guy,
I know many people who put much
more work into their cosplay.
So I'm thrilled that this year
we get to see some more
amazing cosplay.
And now here are the finalists
and winner
of this year's cosplay,
Wizard characters category.
# GUITAR MUSIC
# MUSIC CONTINUES
# ELECTRIC GUITAR MUSIC
# HEAVY METAL MUSIC
# MUSIC SLOWS DOWN
Congratulations to Hartigan
for winning the cosplay award
for best Blizzard character.
Stick around, at the
end of the showcase
to see if they take
home the coveted
Best in show cosplay award.
It's coming up
at the end of the showcase.
But right now,
we have the second place
Digital storytelling piece.
And my friends,
it is a musical delight.
# CLAPS
#SINGS
Let's see it now (#long note)...
Music!
# UPBEAT MUSIC
# I saw an old man
# In a dingy by the sea
# He said he was in a quarantine
# I thought he'd gone mad
from the scurvy
# When he pulled out
his Thunderfury
# And said 6 feet apart
or 6 feet down
# Stand next to me and
I'll put you underground
# No hygiene hell or
take your mask off
# There'll be plague in Azeroth
# So I docked me ship
off the wetland shore
# The town seemed
quieter than before
# No folk in sight
but food at their doors
# Delivered by Goblin Eats
# No Hordor ally in BGs
# Instead they fight
through Zoom meetings
# Everyone's social distancing
# Like that old man said to me
# Six feet apart or six feet
down
# Stand next to me and
# I'll put you underground
# No hygiene hell or
take your mask off
# Will be Plaque in Azeroth
# I seek to find
the source of the Plague
# That drove all of
our heroes away
# I started my search
in Booty Bay
# The foulest place there be
# The goblins point to Zugerub
# I ask Hicar "Corrupted Blood"?
# He said no way, I killed Huzad
# A twenty minute flight are
these
WINGS FLAPPING
(SPEAKING) Excuse me
Can you move ...
Can you move back please?
# Six feet apart or six feet
down
# Stand next to me and
I'll put you underground
# No hygiene hell or
take your mask off
# There'll be Plague in Azeroth
# I'll arrive at Nax and find KT
# He said this Plague
is beyond me
# There's no place with toxicity
# To brew a plague like that
# But starmways they chat
(SPEAKING) Uggh ! Can you please
move your Griffin back
# I spot an old man
from the Dingy
# He's yelling the trade
Thunderfury
# Everybody has one nether city
# And there are all so
scared of Lords
# Fully misinformed
(SPEAKING) I said six f...
SHEEP: Baaaaah!
# It appears that jerks
be the source of the plague
# Bragging about,
they're losing trade
# Going all the casual folk away
# Now no-one wants to play
# But there is still some hope
to see the city
# The Hermy show generosity
# We're all part of one
community
# That's been there 30 years
# So spread love to your peers
# Because Bliiiizaaard is...
# Heeeerre!
All cosplay takes imagination,
artistry, creativity, ingenuity.
But for our category of
traditional creation.
We wanna reward
those who displayed
the highest levels
of craftsmanship
through cutting,
sewing, fastening
and use of classic materials.
So, to announce the finalists
in traditional creation cosplay,
we have Diablo 3 content creator
Wolfcryer.
Hey ladies and gentlemen
my name is James McDermott
but online
I am better known as Wolfcryer,
a Diablo 3 streamer
and content creator.
Also the founder of
Level With a Cause
which is a
charity fundraising event
that coincides
with the start of each
new season in Diablo 3.
We've been doing this
since season 11
and thanks to a ton of
my fellow content creators
and the generosity of
the Diablo 3 community
this effort has managed
to raise over $80,000
for various charities
over the last few years.
2020 brought many challenges
to our daily lives
but gaming and,
in particular for me,
Diablo 3 and
its fantastic community
brought me at least some
sense of that normalcy
that I think we were
all trying to find last year.
Some of my best
memories that I have
have come from Blizzcon.
These are truly moments
that I can never ever forget
and I personally can't wait
until we all have
that opportunity
to meet up in person once again.
But now... here are
the finalists and winners
for this year's cosplay
traditional creation category.
# INSTRUMENTAL MUSIC
# TECHNO MUSIC
# DRUM MUSIC
And now!
It's time to give out
the first place award
for digital storytelling.
And for this piece
a group of Overwatch
community members
came together
from around the globe
to create something
truly fantastic.
Let me tell you my friends,
they delivered the payload.
Let's take a look.
OK, let's get cracking.
Oh, better get my coffee.
FLASH FLASH
All right, good to go
and, right on time.
# BING
Reinhart, how are you?
(DEEP VOICE) Ughh, good I
suppose
but I'm still not sure about
this Internet meeting.
Ohh, you'll get used to it
big guy.
Now can you screen share a plan
of attack on sector seven.
What's share? Share what?
What are you speaking of?
Hold that thought,
Brigitte is in the waiting room.
Where? What room?
Where is my beloved goddaughter?
I do not see her.
BING CAT MEOWING
Brigitte, how are y...
-Uhhhh.
-#Cat miaowing
Ahhh! What is that?
That's just Mitsy
she hasn't had her "Linner" yet.
What's a "Linner"?
Half way between
lunch and dinner.
She gets cranky if she
doesn't get it on time.
No, Mitsy, no! Behave!
-(MISY MEWING)
-Okay, well, anyway.
Here's Genji.
# BING
Uhh, Genji,
we can't hear you.
Genji, turn off mute.
There you go,
what were you saying?
I need healing.
That's worse.
Genji, we need you to focus,
all right.
GENJI BATTLE CRY
What just happened?
OK, moving on, Mei's here.
# BING
Hi, Mei.
WHIRRING NOISE
Oh, May, Stop!
Sorry, sorry, sorry (LAUGHS)
I was just making a milkshake.
A little hot where I am.
Don't you live in the Arctic?
Yes, it's summer here.
(HESITANT) OK.
Nina, I did some research
on the Internet machines.
I can screen share.
That's wonderful.
Now I can finally get
something done.
# BEEPING
Oh, no.
We losing connection.
What is happening?
ELECTRONIC STUTTER
I wish to screen share.
I wish to show my skills.
I live for this
(ELECTRONIC STUTTERING)
ELECTRONIC BUZZING
(ELECTRONIC VOICE)
Hello, Hello...
REINHARDT: Hello
ELECTRONIC WHIRRING
Oh bbbugggg...
ELECTRONIC EXPLOSION
ELECTRONIC WHIRRING
KISS NOISE
# UPBEAT MUSIC
Over the years,
techniques for creating
costumes have evolved
with current technology
which has made for grander
and grander cosplay.
So, right now,
we are going to award those
who have used crafting
technology to its fullest
to bring forth, the most...
epic of modern creation cosplay.
To help us introduce
the finalist,
we have StarCraft Streamer
Livibee.
Hi, my name's Olivia Seedo.
Most people know me
by my gamer tag, Livibee.
I'm a streamer and cosplayer
from Sydney, Australia,
and I've been playing Blizzard
games since I was ten year's old
so they hold a
special place in my heart.
StarCraft is the
hardest game I've ever played
and getting Grandmaster
for the first time
was easily one of the
best moments of my life.
I was finally able to break
through that skill ceiling.
A goal I was driven
to achieve for years
and something
I definitely wouldn't
have been able to achieve
if not for the love and
support of my community.
Streaming has really
allowed for myself and
others to stay connected
during the pandemic.
And even if you're someone
that isn't used to staying
inside all the time,
there's always a place for you
to hang out with people
who share the same passion
for gaming as you do.
Shout out to the Beehive.
For the past year or so
I've also been incredibly
passionate about cosplay.
My favorite character to
cosplay of course is Diva.
She is definitely my video game
character kindred spirit.
But that's enough about me.
Here are the
finalists and winners
for this year's cosplay
modern creation category.
# UPBEAT MUSIC
There's more show to come.
But before we continue
we'd like to take a moment
to recognize one of our
community members
who passed away
earlier this year.
Jarod Nandin took
the Blizzcon stage in 2013
in an unforgettable Southpark
World of Warcraft cosplay.
Creativity
is the defining trait of what
we try to put on display
during community night.
And Jarod...
Jarod was one
of the most creative ones
to ever walk the Blizzcon stage.
Our cosplay community
deeply feels this loss.
Jarod Nandin.
How do you kill
that which has no life?
# MUSIC CONTINUES
# ETHEREAL MUSIC
# DRUM MUSIC
HUMMING
Oh, hi, I didn't see you there
I'm just...
Alone in an empty theatre
creating...
this masterpiece.
(LAUGHING) Yes and
(LOUDLY) paint brush down.
(LAUGHING) Ahaha!
Seriously...
The Blizzard community
creates some of the most
impressive fan art out there.
And a big thank you to all those
who submitted
their fantastic work.
Look, I was a little late
submitting mine
so unfortunately
I could not be considered
to enter the contest
but I will let all of you
give me your opinion.
You be the judge.
It's really good, right?
I'm a very fragile individual.
But, come on.
Let's see who the winners
of this year's art contest are.
And, friends
to announce the finalists,
we have Jazzalene
from the Heroes of
the Storm community.
(LIKE A PIRATE) Haharrgg
Hi guys, my name is Brook,
but most of you know me
as Jazzalene.
I'm from Trenton,
Ontario, Canada
but I've called California home
now for over 4 years.
I stream and I cast
Heroes of the Storm
but I'm also the creator and
organizer of Girls Gank Squad,
an all-female community
created to highlight
and support women in gaming.
In 2020 alone
Girls Gank Squad was
able to raise over $10,500
for charities such as Rain,
the Breast Cancer
Research Foundation
and Marine Toys for Tots.
One of my favorite things
about Heroes of the Storm
is the community.
I've never been
surrounded by such
generous and
compassionate people
They make the events
Girls Gank Squad
put on so successful.
But enough of that stuff.
Every year at Blizzcon
I'm absolutely blown away
by the talented artists
that submit work for
the art contest.
Here are the finalists and
winner of this
year's Art contest.
# EPIC MUSIC
# WARBRINGERS JAINA COVER
(SINGING IN CHINESE)
(SINGING CONTINUES)
Congratulations to Zhon Yung
for winning the art contest
with that amazing
villainous piece.
Well, look, I thought I
was going to introduce
our special guest right now
but there seems to be
a bit of a hiccup.
But look I am from theatre
and uh-uh the show must go on.
MATTHEW: Sorry.
Sorry, I had to finish
putting all this on.
Gun's stuck there... I just
wanna (STRUGGLING) Oh, I got it.
You look great, this is amazing.
One question,
why are you dressed as McCree.
You... asked me to
come in cosplay
for the... community showcase
It's about introducing cosplay.
It's ok, it's fine
You look fantastic
Well, thank you,
much obliged (LAUGHING).
Figured it was
this or the pajamas I've been
wearing for the past 10 months
and I think this has
an air of professionalism
over the previous, so...
I've been wearing a suit
all the time.
That's the epitome
of professional.
Well... (DARREN LAUGHS)
Well, thank you speaking of that
professionalism,
would you help me
bring the hammer down
by introducing the next segment?
It would be an honor,
if you don't mind.
(LAUGHS) So...
The Blizzard
community as we know
does cosplay better than anyone.
So, thank you for the
time spent on
bringing blizzard characters
to life in incredible ways.
So let's take a look at
some of our entrants
in this year's
cosplay exhibition.
# EPIC MUSIC
# MUSIC CONTINUES
And we're back.
Why are you
taking off your costume?
I told you, I've been wearing
it as pajamas for about a year.
It's getting hot.
(SIGHS) However I do
want to say a huge thank you
to all the amazing entrants
to our exhibition.
incredible costumes
and easily one of
my favorite parts every
year here at Blizzcon.
And now my friends, it is time.
The award for this
year's cosplay best in show
will go to one of the four
cosplay category winners.
And to help us present the award
all the way from France...
(FRENCH ACCENT) Here is...
Zeretor.
#TRIUMPHANT MUSIC
And that's it for our
Blizzconline Community Showcase.
-Congratulations to Hartigan
-MATTHEW YELPS
For winning the cosplay
Best in show contest.
-Hartigan.
-Hartigan. (LAUGHS)
And thank you Matt
for joining me every year.
Every time that I get
to spend with you
is more special
than I can possibly say.
Oo, you make me blush.
Truly the honor is mine.
I've been at Blizzcon
since it started and
sharing this space with you is
always an absolute joy.
Thank you.
And, congratulations
to all our finalists.
And thank you
to all the community members who
participated in our showcase.
And finally thanks to
all you watching at home.
Look, friends,
even though we're still
staying safe
by playing a part together,
hopefully, if we're lucky,
we'll see you sooner than later
at our next Blizzcon.
-Until then, I'm Darren.
-And I'm Matt.
Stay safe.
(LOUD VOICE) We love you
MATT BLOWS A KISS
BOTH LAUGH LOUDLY
Welcome to Sanctuary.
We here at Critical Role
are thrilled
to be part of this celebration
of the 30th anniversary
of Blizzard
and of course the announcement
of Diablo II Resurrected.
MATTHEW:
Super excited about it.
As part of that we
we are putting together
this very special,
100% original Diablo one-shot
set in this awesome universe.
I've been a fan
of Diablo since the first one.
It was one of the reasons
I first bought a PC
back in middle school.
I'm old.
Super excited to be able to play
in this space today
with these wonderful people.
Speaking of wonderful people,
let's do a round
of introductions
to our players
for this one-shot,
beginning with
MATTHEW: Mica Burton.
Hi, I'm Mica.
I'm going to be playing a Wizard
and I'm super excited
to kill a lot of things,
because that's
what Diablo's about, right?
MATTHEW: That's kind of
what Diablo's about.
-MATTHEW: You got this.
-Awesome. I got this.
MATTHEW: Laura Bailey.
That and looting, because
that's what I'm here for.
Hi, I'm Laura Bailey
and I'm playing Druid today.
MATTHEW: Brilliant.
MATTHEW: Liam O'Brien.
Hello, I'm Liam O'Brien
and I'm going to be
the Crusader for the group.
I'm excited to be the Tank
in a DnD game
for the first time ever.
MATTHEW: Carlos Luna.
Hey, I'm Carlos Luna.
I'm going to be playing
a Necromancer
with a little demon worm
in his brain.
-LAURA: Like you do.
-Yeah, like you do.
MATTHEW: And Marisha.
Hi, I'm Marisha Ray
and will be playing
a Demon Hunter
not voiced by Laura Bailey,
even though
she's at this table.
MATTHEW: Meta-awkwardness.
MARISHA:
Those were my crossbows.
Is that the sound they make?
I love it. Perfect.
LIAM: We could find
one moment in the game
where you could
throw your voice
and you can just ADR.
-Can you just lip-sync?
-MARISHA: Sure.
Like ADR? Perfect.
Watermelon, watermelon.
LAURA:
Oh, that's good, Marisha.
No more of that.
-MICA: Squash that immediately.
-Exactly.
If you wanna watch
this campaign again
or check out any of the other
amazing, free content
as part of
this BlizzConline event,
visit BlizzCon.com.
Tonight's adventure
that you'll see here shortly
will be available
on our Critical YouTube channel
soon enough.
Thanks to Blizzard and BlizzCon
for bringing us
to be a part of the celebration
and to make this game possible
as part of the event.
I think that's it.
That all being said,
let's go ahead
and jump
into this special one-shot
for BlizzConline.
Diablo.
In the world of Sanctuary,
darkness carries far.
The mortal realm
between the High Heavens
and the Burning Hells,
life in these lands
is ever a struggle
caught in the middle
of this eternal conflict.
The hearts of men
fall easily to corruption
and the Ancient Evil
ever seeks to spill
into this world to sow chaos
and blanket the realm
in fire and shadow.
In a time of shallow peace,
you've each set out
to make your fortunes
in the world,
whether to combat the evil
that lurks
in every lightless space
or to seek answers
to the countless
forgotten mysteries
that call out to the curious.
You've come together
in finding common purpose
against the plague of evils
and made a name for yourselves
in the region of Westmarch.
Here,
you find yourself summoned
by a Horadric scholar
called Deckard Cain.
Under the dim call
of candlelight,
Deckard asked for your aid.
“Hello, my friends."
"I have heard
of your great deeds already
and find myself
in need of others
with such skills as yours."
"The home of my youth,
the humble village of Tristram,
fell to flame
and evil years ago."
"Abandoned,
the ruins of Tristram
have since been nothing
but ash and memories,
often targeted
by looters and grave robbers."
"However,
rumors swirl
of something dark and violent
stirring beneath the cathedral
and,
given the history of that place,
I've a foreboding worry
of what
might be lingering there."
"I would ask you five
to journey
to the ruins of Tristram,
seek the source of these rumors
and cleanse the cathedral
of what terrors
might reside below."
"I'd like to put
the souls of those lost,
finally, to rest."
After braving days
of freezing wind
and the persistent rain
that still haunts you...
CARLOS: 10 out of 10.
Indeed.
Sorry, Michael Gough.
...you finally reach the edge
of the surrounding hills,
looking down
into the ghastly echo
of the village once known
as Tristram.
Walking through the mud
and charred foundations
of what you imagine
was once a modest township,
you can't help but imagine
what horrors must have fallen
upon the denizens.
Slowly, your eyes fall upon
the partially crumbled
stone structure to the north:
the cathedral.
You grasp
at your weapons tightly
as you enter
the semi-fallen structure,
finding solace
within here from the rain.
Stepping across the stone floor,
your vision skips
from broken window
to fallen candelabra
until you find the staircase
descending
into the depths below.
The shine catches your eye,
seeing a single gold coin
resting atop the first stair.
As you descend these steps
into the first layer
of the crypt below...
what do they see
as the Demon Hunter
sets in?
Two heavy footsteps step in
and you see a big skull,
a cow skull, first.
It has detail
of gold filigree emblazoning it,
with a general calf-skull motif
on the rest of her armor,
with little flecks of gold,
and two crossbows.
This is Tauro,
the Demon Hunter,
returning home
to her hometown of Tristram,
but she hasn't been here
since she was a little girl...
growing up on her cattle farm.
And she is definitely
no longer recognizable
to anyone who might know her.
Fair enough. All righty.
Laslo,
get in here.
"Of course, of course."
You see Laslo... step in.
He's a young man.
His forearms
are missing flesh and skin.
It's just bone that you can see.
It's surrounded
by this purple glow around it.
Same thing
with his left calf as well.
He has two scythes.
They look like...
barber blades, shaving blades.
That's how they're shaped,
almost L shaped.
He's very wide-eyed,
but at the same time
you would notice that
his body language
and his eyes
kind of change sometimes
and he starts hunching
and smirking.
And then back
to wide-eyed again.
"Oh yes, right away."
Alright.
As you tumble down the stairway
to follow
the Demon Hunter companion.
Mordred, if you don't mind.
"Shining in the darkness
is Mordred, The Gaunt."
"Not a hair on my head."
"Bald and pale
and dark of eye."
"Sallow-cheeked,
in golden armor of latticework
shining with my Zakara."
"A word I looked up on Wikipedia
earlier today."
"I carry a...
a Morningstar
and a tall, slender shield."
"And I look with a lean
and hungry gaze,
wanting to eliminate
corruption."
"Stay close."
As Mordred steps into
the central landing chamber,
if you wouldn't mind.
Well,
before you even see Remuil,
you hear the swarm of insects
that follows her.
A buzzing
that enters the room
before she does.
She steps in,
hair over one eye,
a bit of a mess.
Green and black armor.
It's more like
vines and reptile skin.
Two snakes
encircle her arms.
They look around.
Her fingernails very long.
She seems happy to be here.
And following in,
the final member of this troupe.
At first, Indra walks in
and she fixes her hair
as it's been messy
on the ride in.
She immediately picks up
the gold off the floor
and scoffs at everyone
who didn't realize
there was treasure lying there.
You see these beautiful raven
feathers encircling her neck,
like a collar.
Very beautiful cleavage
on display
in a tiny,
raven-feathered bra top.
I also saw on Wikipedia that
this is the Wizard couture.
Just one blue swathe of fabric
going across,
making this very skimpy dress.
Interestingly, her right arm
is completely burnt
up to her forearm
and she has gold fingernails.
Probably smelted
from all of her loot.
She has a large staff
that swirls with dark magic
at the end of it.
She says nothing,
but she pockets the gold
into her cleavage.
You got it.
As you all finally descend
the last bit of stairs,
you finally land in the crypt
entryway chambers.
You can see immediately
in the torchlight
that you carry
into this lightless space,
glistening sparkles.
And other smattering
of scattered gold coins,
maybe a dozen or so,
that spill out in the middle
of the old, dusty stonework
that greets you here.
Smell of decay and old, musty,
stale air catches your nose.
You can see
alcove displays nearby
in the sides of the stone walls
and the low ceiling.
Angelic statues
sit within these little alcoves,
though in various states
of disrepair.
While numerous puddles of wax
form at the corners
of various elements of decor,
where candles
once lit these chambers
before they burnt
down to nothing.
A faint growl
echoes in the shadow,
beyond your sight.
As you all continue on a bit,
keeping your eyes peeled,
the pathway
splits into three directions,
a T-intersection.
So (indistinct) in this crypt.
Any indication
of which direction
the growl is coming from?
Make a perception check.
Are there any clay pots around?
Seventeen.
Very good, actually.
The growl,
while the echo seems to be
somewhat
amorphous in the distance,
you listen closely
and can hear a faint bit of...
grinding and another low,
guttural rumble,
similar to that initial growl,
from the path directly ahead.
You rolled a...
Thirteen.
Yeah, there's a pot
right to the left of you.
It smashes
and breaks to the ground,
-leaving 4 gold pieces.
-Yes
Because why wouldn't there be
gold in a pot in a crypt.
Diablo.
Alright
"It seems as if trouble
might be awaiting us ahead."
"Do we wanna start there or...
pick one of the sides?"
"Straight ahead, I say."
"We're here
to eradicate the darkness."
"No point in wasting time,
let's go."
"Bag of bones
so scared on the inside."
does not want to go."
"Onyx does."
And he scurries off.
-"He creeps me out every time."
-"Every time."
"Laslo is in a mood today."
-"Alright."
-"Follow him."
Moving forward.
Laslo, you are taking point
on this one.
Creeping forward,
you initially step through
the stone arches
and you can see they're deep-set
with cracks all around you.
The crunch of shale and bones
breaks beneath you as you step,
loud in your ears amongst
the silence that surrounds you.
The hall carries on
for quite a bit forward
but the walls begin to narrow,
ever so slightly,
before finally coming to an end
where you can subtly see,
with the torchlight
as it approaches behind you,
a pile of corpses
lying on the ground.
Human at one point,
but even just at a quick glance,
you can see that
they're bloody and torn apart.
You guys wouldn't notice that
the back of Laslo has changed
from hunching to up straight
and darting his head
left and right.
"There are...
There are corpses."
-"Yeah."
-"Everywhere."
"We're in a cathedral."
"There's a tomb down here."
"Are you surprised by the fact
that people are..?"
"We knew people
were dead down here."
"I know. I just meant,
yay for us,
we picked the right way."
-"Okay?"
-"Yeah."
"You're not wrong."
How fresh do the bodies look?
You'll have to make a medicine
check to go and inspect.
Do I have medicine?
There should be a skill there.
Doesn't mean
you're any good at it.
There's no medicine.
There's survival.
Sorry.
Medicine.
I did remove that one.
Nature, then.
-Nature.
-Sorry, my bad.
That's not good.
Which is weird,
but seeing how I grew up
in a swamp and all.
Seventeen.
Seventeen?
Not too bad.
Inspecting the bodies,
as you lean down
and look across the corpses.
They... the blood is congealed.
They've been dead
for a little bit of time.
Some of them look fresh,
some of them look old,
almost like something keeps
coming back to feed at times.
But some of them are very fresh
and you can see where then bone
has been splintered and broken.
There are gouges
in the exposed elements
of the heavier white bone
that peaks out.
Teeth marks, claw marks.
"An animal did this."
"I would know."
That growl creeps back in
and you hear it and glance up
and just as you catch
the edge of the torchlight,
the height of the building,
your eyes now see,
lining the upper roof
and ceiling of this chamber
a dozen or so of these
grey-skinned humanoid beings
with elongated limbs,
all hanging, quietly waiting
as the torchlight
glistens past their eyes,
reflecting once.
And in that brief moment of
tension as you hear that growl,
they all begin to leap down
towards you.
Everybody roll an 8.
Oh my god!
As it begins, you see swarming
down 10 of these creatures
begin to surround,
and tear and gnash.
Three of them
are going after you.
are gonna be swarming you.
And then it's gonna be...
We'll do yours first.
So, 3 against you.
It's a miss.
It's a 12 hit.
A miss.
And that does hit.
So, 2 of them
go streaking up towards you,
claws towards you.
One of them holding a giant,
hooked, rusted blade,
swings it wide
and cuts into you
for 3 points
of physical damage.
So, the 3 on you,
not much of an effect.
The 3 that are
storming you, Laslo...
That's gonna be a 10,
which I believe misses.
Eighteen, which does hit.
Better.
Twenty-one.
So, as you're backing away
you have
a swarm of these creatures
rush towards you.
Their jaws open
with horrible, spiked teeth
almost like thick, greenish,
phlegm-like liquid
pouring out of the inside
as they run towards you,
claws out...
as they slash, you take
6 points of physical damage
from 2 who managed
to break through your defense.
These points are not very high.
Two end up swarming
towards you, Tauro.
Twenty-one.
Hits.
And an 11.
Miss.
Alright.
As they both come
swarming towards you,
one jumps up and you catch it
with the side of your forearms
and shove it off
but at that point
the other one crawls up
and starts biting at the side of
your shoulder and clavicle area.
You take 3 points
of physical damage.
And the last 2 would be
1 against each of you.
That is a 24 versus Mordred.
-Hits.
-And a 9 versus Indra.
Hit.
Soo you take 3 points
of physical damage, Mordred,
as 1 of them jumps up
on your shield
and claws over it.
Catches the side
of your forehead,
you can feel the blood begin to
roll down into your eye.
Top of the round now,
Indra, you're up first.
I'm going to electrocute.
You said there were 3 over
here on Remy
Yes.
Okay, I'm gonna try
and electrocute 1 of them
and the 2 other next to it.
You've got it.
-Which is a DC of 16.
-Got you.
So, as you reach out
for your staff with 1 hand,
you see this energy
begin to charge up into your arm
and then suddenly
rocket out towards the 1
and forks off into the other 2
that are next to you Remy,
you watch as the electricity
charges through their body.
What's the DC on that? 16?
Sixteen dexterity.
That's a fail.
A fail.
And a success!
-Darn.
-Go ahead and roll damage.
Alright.
That's 11.
-So, yeah.
-Alright.
Alright.
So, as it shocks
through them all,
they shrink back and scream.
Two of them look extremely hurt,
but they're still holding on
and they're hungry.
They're just running on starving
instinct at this point.
None of them fall, but they're
looking pretty damaged
Are you gonna stay put
towards the back?
As a bonus I'm going to teleport
a little but further
just kind of...
out of any physical range.
Alright, so you just...
You watch as Indra suddenly...
vanishes from sight.
You hear a footfalls
in the darkness behind you
by about 20 or 30 or so feet.
Alright,
finishing your go Indra,
that brings us to Laslo
to run your own deck.
Great.
There's 2 in front of me now?
There's 2 on me?
There's 3 on you.
Three on me, gotcha.
I wanna grab 1 by the head
and cast Siphon Blood.
-Okay, alrighty.
-That's cool.
Okay.
Go ahead
and roll attack on that one.
That is a 12.
Twelve just hits.
So, as you reach out
and grab it and pull it in.
In the light there,
you can see its eyes.
A kind of odd,
milky-white greenish tint to it.
What's the damage on that one?
Nine.
-Nine damage?
-Yeah.
-Alright.
-Sorry.
As you pull out of it you watch
as it screams and squeals
and you pull whatever
element of life force
remaining in this odd
and twisted abomination.
It damages it heavily,
but it still standing
and wriggling in your grasp.
Although you do heal
1 D4 damage from that.
Three.
Okay, but don't forget to mark
your essence from that 1.
Cool.
Do you wanna stay put or
do you wish to move?
As a bonus action,
I'd like to cast Devour.
Devour would require
the corpses nearby.
-Aren't there corpses nearby?
-Oh, there are, yeah!
-Like a bunch of them.
-You can totally do that, yeah.
I was like "They aren't dead...
Other people are?"
Yeah you can.
how many are fresh?
-Within 30 feet?
-Five fresh corpses.
In the sense that their essence
has not been taken.
What a cheerful Necromancer.
Nom, nom, nom.
Fresh corpses.
Fresh baked bread.
-Great.
-There you go.
You go ahead and
get your essence on that one.
And you're staying put?
Will they get an attach
opportunity if I...
-They would.
-They would?
-Yeah, I'll stay put.
-You got it.
That finishes Laslo's turn.
Tauro, you're up,
Mordred, you're on deck.
I am gonna try to shuffle
the 1 that's on me
off a bit and I'm gonna pull out
one of my crossbows and go...
Hungering arrow twice
into the side of its head.
First 1 is a natural three,
which I don't think it hits
with an 11.
Just misses unfortunately.
It's too close to you
and it's writhing in your grasp
and goes wide.
The other 1
is a natural 19 for 27.
That definitely hits.
Which is 1 D6.
Okay, plus 8 damage.
Nice.
So that 1 also goes...
right in the head
and part of it breaks off
and you can see
the open wound there.
It's heavily hurt but it's still
holding on.
Angry and hungry.
Staying put?
Yes.
That finishes your go.
Mordred, you're up.
Remy, you're on deck.
"Roughly how many of these
are there to wound?"
They're all pretty clustered
right now.
You guys
are all in the same area.
There are 10 of them currently
in the middle of this battle.
All of them are within
15 or so feet from you.
-"There's 1 on me?"
-There's 1 on you.
"I'm going to back away from it
intentionally,
risking an attack
and provoke all of them."
Okay.
So, it takes 1 swing at you...
for 20, you take 3 points
of physical damage.
But you manage to pull away and
you're going to provoke.
"All 10 of them need to beat
a DC14 Wisdom save."
"And for every failure,
I rack up Wrath."
Indeed.
Alright.
-What's the DC?
-Fourteen.
First 1 is a success.
Fail.
Wait, did you just...
Success.
Fail.
...lure them all onto him?
-Fail.
-That's a good tank.
Fail.
So, 2 succeeded.
-That's eight that failed.
-Eight total?
So, I'm going to back up
and stop
5 feet in front of Indra.
Drawing them toward me.
They have to attack me
and I now have...
Full Wrath.
There you go.
So, describe how that looks to
the trope.
I back up and say
"Come, lost ones."
-Lost ones? Yes.
-Perfect.
"Make your peace quickly."
The armor just starts to glow
from the latticework
as they start to...
as he backs away towards our...
-You've got it.
-Majorly nerd.
Awesome
You watch all these creatures,
even the ones up in your face,
all of the sudden turn,
except for a couple of them,
turn towards Mordred.
and begin to make their move
when it's their next go.
Remy, you're up.
Okay.
Number 1,
the swarm of insects starts to
get louder and louder
and for my bonus action I'm
gonna have my swarm of insects
swarm the 1 that attacked me.
The 1 that actually
got the hit in.
You've got it.
Alrighty.
There it is...
Go ahead and
roll the attack on that.
Twenty.
Twenty definitely hits.
Alright.
So that does a...
Two D4...
Five...
Seven points of damage...
to the little s**t.
And then...
I would like to hold my attack
until the creatures
move towards...
You've got it.
Although, actually (indistinct)
'cause you start
with a 0 spirit,
you have to build it up,
and that does cost spirit.
-Oh, you start with 0!
-Yeah, you've gotta build it up.
Good to know.
-That's all good.
-I understand now.
In that case, screw it,
I'm gonna maul
the 1 in front of me, too.
Alright, you've got that.
-Okay, so...
-And Instantly...
I'm turned into a...
A giant were-crocodile.
Reptilian, very large,
very large mouth.
Alright,
you're using your action to maul
the 1 that's in front of you.
Go ahead and roll an attack,
well, use the same attack
as you already rolled.
Go ahead
and roll damage for the maul
against the 1 that attacked you.
Seven.
Seven damage is still enough.
As you swoop out,
you watch
as this giant crocodile's face
suddenly sprouts
from the front of Remy
and slams down
onto 1 of these creatures.
Screams from the inside,
muffled once enclosed
in the mouth,
and as the jaw tightens
it goes limp.
Spitting it on to the ground.
Nice.
So, you are currently
transformed
which means you get your AC
while you're shapeshifted.
-Oh, sweet.
-Alright.
That did generate spirit
so you could also swam
now that you have that to use.
Well, I'll do that too.
So, I'll roll for attack
on that 1.
You got it.
That definitely hit,
that's a 21.
Alright, roll damage
for the swarm, now.
Ten.
Ten, that'll do it.
So, after that 1 falls,
you pull back
angry in your gator form.
You watch as the insects swarm
around 1 of the second ones
that was still recoiling
from the shock
that was delivered by Indra,
at the beginning
of this combat round.
As the insects swarm around it,
it begins to screech loudly...
before the silence hit
and the insects pull away.
You see mostly
skeletal upper torso
as it falls to its knees and...
splats to the ground dead.
-Alright.
-Nice.
Are you finishing your round?
Yeah.
Laslo, you're up.
Tauro, you're on deck
Okay.
Actually, sorry,
the creatures have to go first.
So of the swarm that's there,
2 of them have fallen.
There's still 1 against you.
That's gonna be an 11 to hit
which misses.
Goes against you.
Three still up against you,
but actually now
the 3 against you
are going after you.
They begin to rush away
in your direction.
That's a 24 roll (indistinct).
Do you get
an attack of opportunity
against the
ones that ran away?
Yeah.
You can take a singular strike
against one of them
with your Siphon Blood.
Let's do that.
-Fourteen.
-Fourteen does hit.
Roll damage on that.
-Thirteen.
-Thirteen, all right.
The one that's
rushing away from you,
which would have
first attacked him,
so that one's nullified
tries to scoot away.
As it does, you manage
to slam it your Siphon Blood.
As you do, you pull the last bit
of its undead life force out.
It crumples to the ground
and withers on the spot
like a spider
curling its legs in.
(SHUDDERS)
So that first attack
does not actually come at you.
That's my Necromancer!
So, one miss.
And a second miss. They both
come at you, rolling terribly.
The other two
that are coming at you,
one of them stays.
-Okay.
-The other one that succeeded.
That one's gonna be against you.
That is gonna be an 11 to hit.
-Miss.
-Misses.
The other one runs towards you.
You do get an attack.
Although,
you are ranged at this point.
So, I will say
you don't necessarily have that.
That is a 12 against you.
All right. Then there's
the 2 that were already on you.
Twelve and 14.
-No.
-Does not hit.
The last one that's against you
rushes past
and heads towards you as well
That's gonna be a 12.
-They're rolling real bad.
-Back to the darkness.
Now there is a mighty swarm
of these surviving ghouls
that are all scrambling
over and around
the proximity of Mordred,
who's pushing back
with the shield,
flail spinning
in the air angrily,
getting amped up.
That finishes their go,
now we're back to Indra
and then it's Laslo.
I'm gonna electrocute
in the middle,
if they're all piling round him,
just to hit 3 again.
Sure, you can do that.
-Go ahead and roll for attack.
-All right.
Wait, no, it's a DC16.
That's right. (indistinct)
That's a success.
Success.
Wow, they're rolling high.
-And a fail.
-All right.
-Roll damage on that.
-Ten.
Ten damage, so that's 5.
Still takes out one
who was damaged
by the Electrocute before.
Then the other two...
take half damage.
The energy sparks off.
The first one pops from
the pulse of electrical energy.
The other 2 get shaken by it,
but still continue to focus
their attention angrily
on Mordred.
Though some of them are starting
to lose their luster
fighting against
this iron wall of a person.
-Anything else you want to do?
-Yes.
Since Mordred
brought all of them to me,
I'm going to teleport again
on the other side.
Okay, go for it.
(indistinct)
Thanks a lot, Mordred
Indra's playing a teleporting...
chess piece over there,
finishing your turn.
Laslo, you're up,
Tauro, you're on deck.
As soon as
the other guy hits the floor,
Laslo's demeanor changes again.
Now he's kind of
near the ground,
pushing corpses aside
to look for one
that looks just about right.
And Onyx is like,
"Second chance, friend, yes."
"Second chance."
And I'm gonna cast
Command Skeletons
and bring one of them back.
So, you're currently in the
process of this harried combat.
You reach over to find
one of the corpses mostly eaten
and as you draw forth
the undeath from within,
you watch this body.
Suddenly, a skeletal hand
pushes through its own flesh.
It's like watching
a skeleton claw its way
out of the body
that once contained it.
Bones that were broken
and pulled apart...
...snap together.
Until eventually,
you watch this skeleton,
in all of it's still gashed
and clawed glory, stand...
right next to you.
Gruesome. I also love
how you have a spot.
-I can name this skeleton.
-You can if you want to.
It's a pet of some sorts.
-That would be great.
-What's his name?
God. What do you think
would be good?
Spell Slots, that's his name.
-Spell Slots?
-Yeah, Spell Slots.
Because I will be
out of him soon.
You trying to find the right one
gave me a vision
of being
at the grocery store going,
"Which is the right avocado?"
No. No.
Squeeze, squeeze, squeeze.
That skeleton right there.
This has got some good bones.
Skeleton can take a turn
if he wants.
-Really? On this turn?
-Yeah.
I'll send him out to go
hit one of those bad guys
that's running after...
So the skeleton,
immediately after forming up...
lunges forward and takes
a swing at one of the ghouls.
-Fourteen.
-Fourteen does hit. Roll damage.
-Three.
-Three damage.
Not a whole lot,
but doesn't hurt either.
Spell Slots, come on.
He's so cute.
-You can't blame him.
-Spell Slots.
Spell Slots is smaller
than the other skeletons.
-But he's trying his best.
-He's just really tiny.
Perfect.
That finishes your turn?
As a bonus action,
I want to,
while I'm still down there
looking for corpses,
I want to cast Bone Armor.
Okay, go for it.
From the other corpses
you did not choose from,
2 of the other nearby ones,
you watch as sections
of their bone begins to also...
pull out of the flesh,
the soft, easy to tear through
flesh and they begin...
to assemble around you
like this suit of white, pale,
somewhat bloody armor.
I love it.
Six.
So you have 6 temporary hit
points from that.
Awesome,
finishing Laslo's turn,
Tauro you're up,
Mordred you're on deck.
I'm gonna really piss off
at these ones here.
I'm gonna push
the one that's one me off.
I'm gonna spend 12 hatred
to do Rapid Fire.
You got it.
Just full on
every moving body I can see.
So the one that's one me,
the first one...
that was cocked.
Okay, that is 13.
Thirteen to hit?
-Yeah, to hit.
-That hits.
Let's see. These are D6 plus 2.
-Three damage on that one.
-Three damage.
He's still standing. This is
the same one you shot earlier.
He's riddled with holes.
-Fifteen to hit.
-That hits.
Okay, that should do it.
Eight damage.
Takes him out.
Falls to the ground.
-That was 2 shots.
-Four more attacks.
To the one that's...
Actually, I'm gonna go
to the ones that are on Laslo.
Okay.
-Eighteen to hit.
-There's only one left on Laslo.
The other one's
rushed towards...
I think all of them
rushed towards Mordred.
Their backs are
probably turned towards me.
Okay, so the ones that are
rushing away from Laslo.
-Eighteen to hit on that one.
-That hits.
-Seven damage.
-All right. It's still standing.
-But it's real rough.
-I'm gonna hit him again.
-Yikes, 11.
-Eleven does not hit.
I'm gonna shoot at him again.
-That should do it, 18 to hit.
-That hits.
-That's 8 damage.
-That one falls.
And I've got one more shot,
to the next one I can see.
(MUMBLING)
Twelve to hit.
-Twelve just hits.
-Great.
One? Three damage.
You angrily turn around,
channeling your hatred...
and unleash this barrage
of shots in their direction.
You watch
as 3 of these creatures
fall to the ground,
no longer moving.
(PANTS)
-You steady yourself.
-"Filth."
-That finishes your turn?
-That finishes my turn.
Mordred, you're up.
Remy, you're on deck.
I heft my shield and it begins
to emit white, radiant fire
and I will use Shield Bash.
I will charge one of them,
and any of the others
within 5 feet of it
must all make a deck save
and take Holy Damage.
-You've got it.
-"By the Light, be damned!"
You watch as the shield begins
to fill with radiant energy
and with a sudden impacting
blast, like iron on stone,
this echoing explosion
across the inside of this crypt
catches your ears
as you see this flash of energy.
-What's the damage?
-Twenty points if they fail.
Good roll.
That's a fail.
Fail.
And fail.
With that final flash,
you watch
as the bodies go flying
and the few
still standing ghouls
are scattered in pieces
across
the far end of this chamber
as silence
once more takes the interior
of this dungeon.
I...
and turn back
into my human form.
"That was a nice warm-up."
"I think it's agreed, next time
we walk into a hallway,
we check the ceilings."
-"That was unnecessary."
-"But it was fun!"
"I know.
Feeling really good, actually."
"You're not the one
covered in goblin parts."
"No, I actually look
pretty damn good."
"All right.
Shall we continue on?"
This is the end of the hall.
It ends here, at the bodies.
It narrowed and came to an end.
"Well (BLEEP), we went
the wrong way. Turn around."
Is there anything else?
-Any clay pots?
-Any pots?
There are 3 pots, no chests.
There are the tattered corpses
and 3 pots.
I wreck one of them.
Is nobody else claim the other
pots? I'm going for it.
LAUGHTER
All right, you have to teleport.
I'm just saying.
Because right now,
there's a weregator
that is just wading into them.
Can I use my maul action
to maul the clay pot?
I'll allow it. You don't need
spirit for that, but you can.
I've got a sheath of unpuffed
bubble wrap before I go.
-Okay, you do that.
-I want one pot.
One pot bursts with arc energy
from your magic missile,
causing it to scatter
across the chamber.
-Four gold drops on that one.
-Yes!
The two are the ones
that you tear into, Remi...
One of them
contains 40 gold pieces.
Oh, s***!
And the other is empty.
Okay, well, that was worth it.
It is strange, though.
Most things
you hit in this world
do tend to erupt
into gold coins.
-I agree.
-Strange? How's that strange?
I try not to question it.
Where do they come from?
I once hit a waffle and
it turned into three gold coins.
We're one act away
from the Truman Show.
Videogame.
Maybe there's another realm,
where there's
just piles of gold.
Pocket dimension.
A distant echo
of some distant screech
suddenly cuts you off this deep,
metaphysical conversation.
(indistinct)
LAUGHTER
Did it come
from the left or the right?
Did you hear that? The narrative
structure is calling us.
I feel a deep calling.
-Nice.
-(indistinct)
It sounded pretty muffled,
but nothing beyond that, really.
Did you hear the call?
Something's around.
Which direction?
I don't know. I couldn't tell.
It was muffled.
Did anyone else hear it?
No, you were
having conversations.
Oh. We were talking
about metaphysics.
I'm going to go back to
where the three branches start.
Back yourself out a little.
You're back
at the T-intersection
facing in the direction.
You have right and left.
I'm gonna hold my wrist up
and let my snake
lick the air and see if it
points in a certain direction.
Oh, that's cool.
Okay.
The snake
is unfamiliar
with crypt environments
and is uncertain how
to tell which direction to go.
It's all right, baby.
You'll get it someday.
It slithers sadly
back onto your wrist.
Familiars can sometimes
be disappointing.
I went to press
my ear to the ground
to see if I can hear where
the calling is coming from.
-Make a perception check.
-Okay.
-Nineteen.
--Nineteen. Not bad.
As you put your ear against
the stone of the ground,
you hear faint scraping noises
from both directions.
Which scraping sounds eviler?
There's more of them
to the right.
A more independent
and fainter one to the left.
Okay/
The right seems dangerous.
The left also seems dangerous.
-Take your pick.
-What are you feeling?
I'm feeling...
If we're looking for some fun,
we go to the right.
If we're looking to stay safe,
we go to the left.
-Right, it is.
-Let's go to the right.
-You guys are psychopaths.
-Yeah.
All right.
You all travelled to the right,
for about 15 feet, as you all
have your weapons at the ready.
Eyes peeled, you come upon
a massive, solid, iron door.
There are chains pulled
across the front of it
and a heavy lock fixed to it.
Hmm, I actually might
be able to handle this.
-I'm gonna try and pick it.
-Okay.
Go ahead and roll a D20.
Add your dexterity modifier.
Okay.
Ew. My dex... Just--
-Just your dex.
-Straight dex. Okay.
Oh, poop! That was almost great.
Fifteen total.
-Oh, sorry. Thirteen total.
-Thirteen.
Okay, with the thirteen,
you watch
as your awesome bad***,
down in
her home turf Demon Hunter
gets down and takes out
her thieves' tools.
Yes.
And with a whip of the wrist,
you achieve nothing.
It was not budging.
Do we need to get a key?
What about your horns?
No. I just...
Just give me a moment.
I just punch it.
I just try and punch it
like The Fonz.
Make a strength check.
Tauro, Tauro.
Why couldn't that
be my lockpicking check?
What's my strength?
I have no... 18.
Eighteen? Good roll.
Your knuckles are bleeding.
Blast!
Yeah, we need to find a key.
With a heavy impact
against an iron door,
the echo on the other side...
Boom!
Definitely reverberates
through the nearby chambers.
You get the sense that,
with any sense of surprise
you may have had at this point,
you've definitely made
your presence known
in the proximity of this door.
It was the door's fault.
Well, the surprise is ruined.
I'll just magic missile
the lock.
Okay.
Go ahead and roll some damage.
All right. Just damage?
I don't need to roll the hit?
-Roll the hit just in case.
-Okay.
-I like ones.
Seventeen.
-Does that hit the door?
-It hits.
-Go ahead and roll damage.
-I shall.
-Four plus two. Six.
-Okay.
You blast it once.
Glancing at it,
this is a very heavy door.
With the magic missile,
the arcane blast from it
is generally pretty powerful
against softer, fleshier things.
It's not gaining any purchase
against this door's lock,
unfortunately.
Yes, it's the door's fault.
Find another way around.
Maybe there's a key
down the other hallway.
To the left.
Look for keys, all the while.
Yeah.
Place my hand on the door
before we go.
We'll play later.
-F*** doors.
-Spell Slots goes like...
Spell Slot.
Glad you're with us, buddy.
Spell Slots is the best.
He's my favorite character
in this adventure.
Continuing onward
in the other path,
there's a relatively
lengthy hallway
that continues on for a bit.
There are pots here,
but they're already broken.
-Oh...
-What?
What?
You do eventually, quietly,
come upon a left-hand turn,
and in the next hall,
you can just faintly hear...
movement,
scrambling,
footfalls and shifting scrapes
against the stone.
Is there anything
on the ceiling?
-Make a perception check.
-Okay.
Someone knows the secrets
of the pots.
-It's a very competent four.
-Gosh.
Glancing up
at the ceiling above,
which is only
about a 10-foot ceiling
at this portion of the tunnel,
and with the torchlight,
you do carry,
you're pretty sure there's
nothing on the ceiling, but...
who knows.
We're absolutely safe.
-I'm gonna scurry ahead.
-Yeah, peek around.
Yeah. Can we see what's making
that scurrying noise ahead?
Can we...?
-Scooby-Doo?
-Yeah.
One by one,
the heads go boop, boop!
They appear in a totem.
You can see,
in this next chamber,
a cluster of pots
and small cases,
all open or broken
in various states,
and there is a dressed humanoid.
You see from the back
that it's currently
rummaging
through one of these right now.
You can see some coins
spill out of its grasp.
It reaches in and snatches them
and puts them in a pocket
and is just talking to itself.
-Is it a goblin?
-Oh my God. Is it a goblin?
-Is it a treasure goblin?
-It's hard to see from the side.
"Kill him!" I just yell.
(indistinct)
MIMICS GUN
Roll attack.
(indistinct)
Get away!
I've blocked the door,
blocked the hallways,
so it can't run.
Roll to attack twice.
Actually, do I...?
Will I get hatred for this?
This is the first round
of combat.
Actually, I can't. I wouldn't
have enough hatred, so no.
Hungering Arrow.
Okay. Two... Those are both.
That's a natural 20 and an 18.
-A natural 20?
-Yeah.
That's a critical hit. Yeah.
Roll damage on both,
doubling the dice damage
on the first one.
Okay.
What do I roll? New class.
Okay. First one. That's a 4,
so 8 doubled, plus 5.
So, 13. Wait, no.
-Yes.
-Eight doubled, plus five.
No, no. 4 doubled.
Oh, got you. Got you.
So, 4 doubled is 8. So 8 plus 5.
-That brings it to 13.
-Thirteen damage on the crit.
And then, for the other one,
I rolled a one on damage,
so 6 total.
Gotcha. Okay.
So, 19 damage total.
So, as you close the door...
Fire above these.
The individual turns around and
you see, for a brief second,
just a dude
in normal clothes,
with a small package,
who just goes,
"What?
Argh!"
Treasure goblin!
He spits blood out of his mouth,
and there are two crossbow bolts
on his chest and he's like...
-Oh!
-"Argh!"
Who?
Was I not...?
Was I not supposed to?
He falls onto the ground
and he's like bleeding out.
-Ooh.
-Ah! Run away.
Run to him. "Do you have a key
to the lock on the other side?"
"Who are you?"
-Oh.
-Splitting blood.
-Like...
-Just let him die and Laslo--
...consecrate the ground
under this man.
-Oh!
-Oh, really? Okay.
He starts to heal. So does
everyone standing around him.
Ooh, really? Okay.
Four rounds of one D6 plus 2.
What were you saying, Indra?
I was gonna say
if you let him die,
Laslo would have talked to him
and it have been much easier.
He begins to heal up
a little bit of his wounds.
Take the arrows out.
He sits up and says,
"No, no. What do you want?
Okay, stop.
I have to get to him."
He grabs the bag
and ignores you until he goes
back into the boxes,
and takes whatever he can find
and throws it in the sack.
"Give what for whom?"
"For the child."
It needs me. It needs
all the treasure and valuables."
"Don't think about it."
The eyes glance past all of you
as his wounds heal back to full.
Whoa, whoa.
I just transformed my arm
into a crocodile arm.
I'm a werecrocodile.
That means my arms--
I know, I know.
-Just like a crocodile.
-Fair enough.
I was picturing the crocodile
with fur, though.
Me too!
(indistinct)
Sanctuary ecology is a little
different than earth ecology.
Crocodiles here, be furry.
-Okay.
-However you wanna picture it.
Wild look in his eyes,
he's surrounded by 5
well armored dungeon delvers.
At this point,
he is wearing normal clothing
and is currently holding,
in one hand, this half-open bag
and with the other,
pulls out a dagger and goes...
"Give me your belongings!
Give me your valuables!"
I pull out my crossbows
and point them at him.
Annex is very happy
at all of this.
"Kill him again. Do it again."
See, Annex knows what's up.
"Honestly...
you're about 5 seconds
from that being your reality,
if you don't stop and tell us
what you're doing."
"He'll kill me if I don't bring
enough back for him."
-"Who's the child?"
-"The child below."
"Through the door, with a lock?"
"Beyond that, aye!"
"So you have a key?"
"Maybe."
"Tell you what...
We'll bring all your treasure
to the child for you."
"No, no. I have to do it.
l have to."
"All right,
how about an exchange?
You can come with us."
"Okay.
When we get there,
you'll give me your belongings?"
"Sure.
What's your name?"
"Johnny."
-"Johnny?"
-"Johnny."
"Nice to meet you, Johnny."
-"Yeah. Give them to me."
-"Not now."
"I'll keep it, then."
-"Sure."
-"Okay."
And he lifts the bag up
over one shoulder like this.
Half-crazed...
Santa-gnome figure...
blinks a lot in front.
"So, go on. Follow him."
I really did think
he was a treasure goblin.
I did, too.
I was about to confirm
all of my theories
for this
other dimensional realm,
which is filled
with gold and treasure.
I was this close.
I know it's real.
I'm regretting my choice
to bring this man back
from the brink.
Looks over you
with this mostly gum-filled,
occasional tooth grin.
GROWLS
-Well...
-"Oh, oh, wait."
He reaches into his pocket
and pulls out
this long rusty key and goes,
"Here."
He pulls a dagger out.
"There you go."
You know what? Have a seat.
If you want me
to help you all...
I need to meditate for a while.
How long?
Thirty to sixty minutes.
(indistinct)
-We just got started.
-I know.
We'll just do a montage.
It's fine.
What's a montage?
It's a great hotel.
It's with a bunch of activities
that have taken a long time
and shortened
to an easy-to-grasp scenario.
Let Johnny and Spell Slots
put arrows in--
Oh, I love him.
-Tauro does push-ups.
-Yeah.
Are you taking a rest here?
If the game
and the group will allow it.
That's up to you, guys.
I'll just mark it here.
-Mark it.
-Good.
Things are happening below.
It's up to you.
It's skin off your backs,
not mine.
All right, I guess. Fine.
-Okay.
-I think it's a good idea.
We could ask our little friend
a little bit more
about "Johnny"?
"We're not going?
We're not moving."
"Well..."
-"Thirty--"
-"You were hurt.
And he had to heal you.
So, now he needs to rest."
Could have been avoided
if we'd let him die like I said,
but whatever.
-Well--
-He's looking through his bag.
He's ignoring the questions
for the moment.
He's checking,
counting things...
"What is it? Okay."
Spell Slots,
do you know
any good musical routines?
Lazlo is not excited
about Spell Slots.
He has become
a stepdad overnight.
He's (indistinct)
all the attention.
Laslo's not very happy
about Spell Slots.
But what did you ask? I'm sorry.
If he knows
any good musical numbers.
Hey, buddy.
Can you play those things,
like a xylophone or something?
Do you know any...
Kanye or do you know...?
What can you do?
What is... What is his...?
(indistinct)
The Soca Room is a well-known
travelling bar.
(indistinct)
I was...
Oh, just deep tracks?
God, Spell Slots!
Give me some hits.
This skeleton mainly sits
in a dark house vicinity.
Not quite hitting the right
vibe for you, unfortunately.
But it's the only skeleton
you've got at the moment.
Well, say, you finish
your 30-minute period of rest.
When it comes to an image,
you all stand at the ready.
You can see that Johnny
is looking very impatient,
pacing, going,
"Come on, come on," to himself,
his eyes looking
at nothing in particular.
Then you hear
this distant shriek...
down the hallway, just like...
MATT SHRIEKS
Oh, come on.
A ghoul...
-That was really cool.
-Creep.
-So, what are you gonna do?
-All right.
Are you feeling better?
Come on, autotune skeleton.
Let's go.
That's not even early Kanye.
All right. As you head back
towards the large iron door,
indeed, the key does open it.
As the door...
.opens to the side,
you can see
there's an annexed portion
of the chamber.
The hallways curves
to the right slightly.
And following with the light,
eventually, that opens
into wide archways
and this faint glow
of candlelight
that greets you
on the opposite side.
You can see a beautiful display
of large statues
depicting angelic figures,
a central one
in heavy armor and hood,
that's looming
over a wide staircase,
the hood itself empty,
sword in front.
You can see
this staircase descends below,
but standing
before this armored figure,
you see a humanoid shape,
wearing its own haphazard armor,
turned away from you.
And as it spins...
you see this...
skeletal entity
wearing old rusted,
dusty Horadric armor.
As it looks back
towards you all,
as you spin
around the edge, it...
And as it races its hands,
you can hear
the sound of scratches,
as the walls you now notice
are filled, ceiling to floor,
with stone tombs
that begin to spill.
MATT MIMICS TOMBS CRASHING
The lid spilling open
as skeletons scramble out
in your direction.
They swarm towards you,
as the one-armored skeleton
begins to curl
its hands in the air.
And you see arcane runes swirl
on the floor in front of it.
I need all of you
to roll.
Oh boy...
Whatever.
We've got a skeleton, too.
It's true.
All right. Top of the run.
Remi, Laslo, you can see now,
one central armored skeleton
that stands taller than the rest
that is currently in the process
of some sort
of dark purple incantation.
The energy is swirling off it
and the rune on the ground
begins to break.
You can see now
four other skeletons that
have crawled out of the tombs,
drawing rusted weapons
and beginning to scatter
their way towards you.
And in the back of the room,
two of the skeletons that fell,
bringing a total of six,
have bows and arrows
and begin to reach back,
pulling them taut.
So, here we go.
8 D8s and heartbreak.
-What are you two doing?
-I'm gonna whip my arm up.
And my snake's gonna shoot
forward from my arm,
and a spiritual blade
is gonna shoot forward
towards the armored creature.
-Oh, cool.
-And I'm gonna cast Windshear.
You've got it. Okay.
Go ahead. Roll an attack for it.
Which one? The one in the armor?
-Yes.
-Okay.
Seventeen to hit.
-That indeed hits.
-Yes!
So, that's 3D 8.
Matt, you said there was...
one big baddie and two...?
Two archers
and four melee skeletons.
Okay. And one big baddie?
-Yeah.
-That's okay.
So, 11 damage.
Eleven points of damage.
Not bad.
But my movement
has increased by 10 feet
until the end of my next turn.
Indeed. Don't forget to generate
eight spirit from that.
Yes.
All righty.
As the blast of razor-sharp wind
arcs off your hand
and strikes the creature,
it shears off
part of its shoulder armor.
It cracks in the bone.
You see his thing damaged from
the impact, but it stands there,
continuing to cast,
its arm
still undulating in space.
How far away is it from me now?
You guys are at the entrance,
so that's about
15 feet from you.
And the melee skeletons
quickly rushing in
at the same plain.
The archers are about 30 feet
from you in the distance.
I'm gonna run forwards
since I've got
extra movement speed.
I'm gonna run forward.
I'm gonna run towards
the armored guy,
just straight into the middle.
Easily enough.
Then I'm gonna throw a
bonus action cast swarm at him.
You've got it.
All right, as you rush forward
towards the front,
in your awesome druid...
swamp druid form.
Dart towards him. As you do,
you bring your arm up.
And out of the inside of
your outfit, insects crawl out
and whip around this creature.
-Which roll to attack?
-Fifteen plus seven.
Fifteen plus seven hits.
Roll damage for that.
-Six points of damage.
It's swirling around inside.
Since this is not
a fleshy creature,
you can hear them buzzing
and hitting the inside
of the rib cage.
The armor from the interior
is sustaining damage,
but not as much
as you would hope
given the circumstances.
But you are now
right in front of it.
You can see, within its
deep, sunken, dark sockets,
these faint points
of glowing purple energy
matching the same arcane force
that its currently
calling to it.
That finishes your turn.
You are right in the center now.
All eyes are currently on you.
Laslo, what are you doing?
As Remi starts to run forward,
Laslo gets down on one knee
and starts punching the cement.
And I'm gonna cast Death Nova.
So, all this smoke
is coming up... above him.
But below him, I guess.
You got it.
So, it's a DC 15
constitution save.
It is. It's also all creatures,
just so you know.
That does include
your friends too.
So, you're gonna
wanna try to maneuver.
Yeah, so, if he's 15 feet...
Is she right at 15 feet
or at 10 feet?
She's 15 feet ahead of you.
You'd have to go far to one side
of the other to avoid her.
-Yeah, let's do that.
-Okay.
Right or left corner?
Left. We've avoided left
this entire game.
You got it.
To the left.
You Zoolander over
to the left-hand corner,
punch the ground
and this green energy swirls up
and with the impact,
darts outward.
All this toxic, poisonous,
magical energy
radiates outward and swarms
into and hits the two skeletons
and the central skeleton.
It's a minimal effect.
Go ahead and roll damage.
Twelve.
-Twelve damage.
-All right.
You've got it.
It hits them.
You watch
as they withdraw from this.
They do all fail their saves,
but even so,
poison doesn't seem
to have the same impact
on the skeletal entities.
You realize that moment,
like, "Damn!"
Did some damage, but not as much
as you'd have hoped.
And Spell Slots can take
his turn as well, if he'd like.
Go, Spell Slots!
Getting ready for it. Yeah.
He's gonna make a melee attack
at the closest one.
You got it. All right.
-Eleven.
-Eleven does not hit.
Spell Slots.
He goes... and arcs wide
and hits off the bones now.
It's just skeleton
and skeleton slap fight.
He's a college drop-out.
Hey, game in the room
for a little bit.
That finishes you turn, Laslo?
-Yes.
-All right. Mordred, you're up.
Yes.
I'm going to charge in
and run up alongside Remallia.
And as I do, I'm going
to recite the Laws of Justice,
so that I and my companions
are resistant to cold, fire
and lightning damage for a bit.
Takes away 4 points of wrath and
I will punish the big baddie.
with two swings
of my Morning Star.
You've got it.
As a note for you as well,
which I just recalled,
after you strike,
the creature insects
swarm around it.
And this pulse of energy
comes off it.
You watch as these
arcane needles shoot out
in your direction.
And you did on that one.
You took...
five points of fire damage
as they blast on you.
It seemed to almost reflect
some of the damage back at you.
-What do you do on your turn?
-I...
Bonus action
from Laws of Justice,
which gives resistance.
I don't know if it was in time.
Not for her, but it will
for the next round.
Cold fire and lightning
till the start of my next turn.
And then I used Punish,
so I got two attack actions,
and when I rolled,
I got 22 on both.
Both of those hit.
Perfect. That is one D8.
Five plus seven.
Six is thirteen.
This is against the armored one?
-Hm-hmm.
-The armored one--
-Against the... cast.
-You've got it.
That buffs up my own AC a bit
and charges my wrath again,
and that's the end of my turn.
That was 13 damage
for both of those.
All told.
You've got it. All righty.
So, as you go ahead and strike
with both of those,
your flail hitting at the side,
once again over the shield.
Each impact blasts into you and
you can see it from the impact.
And that same...
arcane energy seems to...
fire that damage back out at you
as these two spears
of burning white hot magic.
That is a 13 that misses you.
But a 24 does hit you.
You take...
It would be 7 points
of fire damage,
but because of your resistance,
it reduces it to 3.
Nice. Good call.
All right,
finishing up Mordred's turn
is now Kresh
the Unforgiven's turn.
-Kresh?
The Unforgiven?
The armored skeleton you can see
now finishes its casting,
and as it does,
in the center of the floor...
a new skeleton appears.
You get the sense this one can
just bring more skeletons.
-That's a sense we get, guys.
-You get a sense of that.
It's a weird thing
about that one
See if that recharges.
Yeah, it recharges.
It is going to then
do a burning dart,
as it's standing right there.
It's gonna go ahead
and fling the dart at you
since you're the one
who first came at it.
And you're the one...
actually it's gonna go for you
since you're the one
who did the most damage to it.
Natural 19.
That's put it at a 23 to hit.
So you take 10 fire damage
reduced to 5
as it blasts into your face.
The shield catches part of it
and the rest of you lawful
defense manages to shrug it off.
That feels good.
Finishing its turn, that brings
us to Tauro and Indra.
Do you want me to go first or..?
What is the new scales
and holding?
Is it a melee
or is it an archer?
-That is a melee.
-Okay.
Try executioner's axe actually.
-Why did I ask?
-Charming.
-You can go first.
-Okay.
I'm just gonna slowly walk up,
drawing my crossbows
I'm gonna say
"if it bleeds, you can kill it."
And I'm gonna cast
Mark for Death.
"Well,
the big vein bleeds a little."
Right?
"It bleeds a little, guys."
You all go "yeah".
I don't wanna do
hungering arrow.
We got there.
The whole group is like
"yes, and..."
Don't stop for improv.
You know that I don't want
to jack your job.
Don't worry.
It's not my fault
this is the line
that they've set for disability.
Alright.
So what are the rules?
And you're respecting
which ones?
I'm gonna attack,
just 2 hits of the big baddie.
You got it.
Okay, so that first 1 is a 17
and the second attack is a 23.
Both hit.
Go ahead and roll damage.
And these are extra-D6's,
because he is marked.
So, for the first 1...
Okay, lets...
11 damage total.
11 damage, you got it.
For the second 1...
Go ahead.
...is a...
13 damage total.
Nice.
So, as you come around and...
You fired twice out
of the arrows
Hit the arm and you can see
another chunk falls off.
The bones are
now splintering
from the impact they have taken.
It's having a hard
time holding itself together.
And all the other skeletons
around it
are eager to rush in
and try and offer protection.
You also notice...
Not bleeding.
Not yet.
-Yet, exactly.
-Go back to the writers.
Systemic dialogue.
Roll with it.
Alright, finishing your go.
Indra.
-Question.
-Yes.
-Big baddie is here.
-Yeah.
My friends are in front of him.
-Directly?
-Directly in front of him.
However,
the archers are behind him.
How close
would you say they are?
They'd be about 15 feet.
Wonderful!
As in a 15 feet diameter
could catch...
both this big baddie
and these archers.
Cool.
Then I'm going to...
Flick my hair behind my...
get it caught on my lip-gloss
like a cool person
and then I'm gonna cast a meteor
right in the middle.
Okay.
-Okay.
-Yes.
Hoping to end this quickly.
Indra is just gonna
scoff as she...
summons a giant meteor from...
-...above?
-Yeah.
-So...
-No?
As you watch,
Idra pulls the staff forward.
(indistinct) kinda spins
her staff in the air.
You're all engaged in this
skeleton until you hear this...
This horrible, tearing sound
and you all can't
help but glance up
As in the air above
this staircase,
and where this battle has taken,
you see a slither of reality
is suddenly carved and open.
And you see
a dark expanse of stars.
And purplish-blue mist.
And from that, a bright light
as a flaming rock...
appears out of it
and slams into the top of
the staircase and explodes.
You can see flames.
Just spirals around
and almost engulfs both of you
at the front of this battle
but just manages
to singe your eyebrows.
You don't have any
so you don't have to worry
But it does catch you
a little off guard.
This thing called
hair on my body.
Go ahead,
roll damage on that.
I had to bring out
extra D6's for this one.
Good lord.
Twelve.
Who's good at math here?
-No.
-Best luck.
-Just say it.
-Okay
Twelve plus eight.
Plus 5
Plus 5.
Plus 7.
Thirty-seven
points of fire damage.
And you spell DC on that one?
-Sixteen dex.
-Got it.
Failure to crush the unforgiven.
-Failure on the archer.
-Love hearing it.
Failure on the other archer.
As the flames and explosion
die down for a second,
the sound you hear
is the clattering
of scattered bones
raining down from the opposite
side of the chamber.
As the 2 archer skeletons
are blown apart
and thrown
across the opposite side.
The central skeleton armor
you now see as it looks out
the purple light in its eye
blinks out,
and the bones...
scatter on the inside
and hitting the ground.
Destroyed.
Indra brushes off
some dust of her shoulder
and is like "Pathetic."
The big guy?
Yeah,
he just fell to the ground,
but there are still
4 other skeletons.
Five technically,
one with a giant axe.
And it's now their turn.
Where's the dude
we came in here with?
Is he hanging back?
He's not in this battle.
-He's in the hallway.
-He's back there?
Yeah, with his dagger.
"I'm Johnny,
what do you want from me!"
-And the one-liner: I'm Johnny!
-"I'm Johnny!"
He is hisown movie
right now.
Exactly.
With the proper NPC,
once you cycle the dialogue,
he just has
the one thing to say.
"I'm Johnny!"
Two skeletons
rushing up towards you.
Remy?
Going to strike.
That's a natural 20.
That's 8 points
of physical damage.
And the other 1
is gonna be a 20 to hit.
Four points physical damage.
A total of twelve against you.
Cool.
Other 2
are rushing up against you,
since you're right in the front.
That's a 1, which misses.
Another natural 20.
You take 8 points
of physical damage
from that secondary strike.
Okay.
And they're just swarming
at you, hacking away.
And the 1 with the...
executioner's axe...
let's roll to see
which 1 of you it goes after.
You.
I'm sitting there going.
Just looking over at him
suggestively.
-So, here's the thing.
-If it bleeds, you can kill it.
They're aware.
As the 2 skeletons rush
and you're fighting them off
you can't help
but in the background
see the 1 skeleton
glance up at you.
It's head cocked to one side,
as it slowly lifts
this massive axe
that weighs immense amounts.
-Oh no.
-'Sup buddy.
Large swing,
right into the ground,
about a foot from you.
Not a great aim
on this skeleton.
Probably used to using an axe
and just completely
misses entirely.
Kind of looks at you...
"This is awkward,
I feel bad for you."
And it's now wedging
out of the ground
which brings us back to
Remy and Laslo's go.
Wait, are they in a line?
They are pretty close to a line.
Actually, 3 of them
are in a line.
Doesn't matter,
can't do it anyway.
Hold on.
"But they're close
to each other?"
"They're within 5 feet
of each other."
Three of them are, yes.
Yes, screw it.
"I'm gonna...
...look up...
and find a big piece of rock
from the pile of meteorite
that fell down."
You got it.
"I'm gonna lift it up
and cast Landslide
on 3 of the creatures
in front of me."
Hopefully including the one with
the giant executioner's axe.
Go ahead and roll attack
for all 3 of them.
Executioner's axe
and the 2 next to him.
-Get it Stevie Nicks.
-Ah, he beat me to it.
And if you see my reflection...
The first one is...
-Who was singing there?
-Oh no, damn.
The first one is 17.
That hits.
Do I add anything?
Oh, yes I do.
The first one is 24.
That definitely hits.
The second one is 13.
Just hits.
Why do you still have your...
And the last one
definitely hits, it's a 23.
**** natural damage
for each of them.
-Okay.
-This is individual.
Three D10.
Executioner first.
Three plus nine is twelve
plus six is eighteen.
Eighteen, other two?
Nine, fifteen...
Seventeen.
Okay.
Five plus six
is eleven on the last one.
Got it.
So, as you pull up
a chuck of the meteor
that was summed
through space by Indra,
you lift it up to the ceiling
with a crack impact
that brings elements
of dirt and earth
and rock from above.
As it slams down
to the central space,
broken apart
from the multiple impacts,
it cause a shower
of sharp shards of rock, stone
and whatever piece
of the nearby structure
that was carved free from it,
and as it does,
you watch the executioner
skeleton axe high in the air
for a secondary
strike is smashed beneath it,
flattened into a bunch
of broken pieces of bone.
The 2 other skeletons
to its side look up...
and are simultaneously
smashed as well.
We're down to 2 skeletons,
that brings us to you, Laslo.
Are they in a row?
They're in a row,
but distant from each other.
They're on opposite ends.
I'd say 30 feet from each other.
I'm just gonna run up to 1,
place my hands on its head
and Siphon it.
Can it Siphon its blood?
Does it have blood?
Siphon life.
Life, yes.
It's a little more
of an essence.
-Exactly.
-'Cause video game.
Nineteen.
Nineteen does hit.
Go ahead and roll damage.
Mordred, you're on deck.
-Ten.
-Ten damage, that does it.
As you reach out
and extend your hand towards it,
you watch as it
(indistinct) and shake
and what faint bit of magic
still remains holding it
animate is pulled away.
The skeleton almost seems
to implode in your direction
sending bones scattering
to the ground by your feet.
And you heal up on D4.
Awesome.
-Four.
-There you go.
While I'm doing this Spell Slot
is running to the other side.
-To hit the other dude?
-To hit the other dude.
-You got it.
-It's so sad.
I'm picturing him a lot smaller
than the other guy.
Let's see what he does.
He's trying so hard.
The way you keep describing him,
I imagine him in Yeezys.
-Yeezys and joggers.
-Yeah!
Fourteen.
Fourteen does hit.
What's the collateral damage
for the last standing skeleton.
Three.
Three damage.
Big old heavy fist fall
into the skeleton, which takes
the hit but it's still standing.
It's looking damaged
but it's still standing.
That finishes...
what else have you got?
I'm gonna cast Devour again,
if there's a bunch...
oh, they're not corpses
they're skeletons
-They're...
-Do they could as corpses?
They technically
would not count as corpses.
-Then that's it.
-Sorry.
Philosophical question,
are skeletons corpses?
So, 2 are upright?
-One is up.
-Just one?
Yes.
I just hoist up
my Morningstar and say,
"I hate to do it
No I don't"
So, it's pulverized?
-First this is...
-A punishment.
Very low role-reversed.
That's a 10.
Ten misses.
And a very low roll for
the second so I hate to do it,
so I don't do it. 12.
-Twelve does hit.
-Does hit?
Skeletons don't have
huge AC necessarily.
Oh, but it's a 1 on the damage,
so 4 points of physical damage.
Four points physical damage.
Still standing.
You do about
as much damage as...
(indistinct)
The skeleton looks mad at you.
Trying to blow it over the rest
of the way.
It's mad-dogging you
from its eye-less sockets.
Cresh is gone
so now it's Tauro and Indra.
Alright, I...
I'll just look at Indra and say
"Mind if I do the honors?"
-Go for it.
-Just pull out a dagger.
I'm gonna do my impale.
Go for it.
Come on, 17 or 20!
I got a 19!
Or an 18!
-That's a crypt!
-That's a crypt.
You can't see it but
we're not far from each other.
Expression says it all.
That get a critical hit
on 17 or 20.
-Yeah.
-Or 17 through 20.
And it's 2 D12 damage.
Wait, let me get another D12.
I never get to do this.
...one hit point left is.
Just wait for it.
Socially distant DnD.
Here we go.
I never get to roll D12s,
this is awesome.
Okay.
So, that's 9 damage, so 18,
plus 5.
-Twenty-three points.
-Twenty-three points of damage.
This skeleton is taking
blow-after-blow
and it's standing
resolute against you
and your companions around you
as it turns towards you.
The dagger comes towards it
as time slows,
sit there contemplates
in those final moments.
Gary Jules playing
Mad World right now.
It considers...
nothing as it's a skeleton,
it has no mind.
Whereas the other skeletons
exploded into chunks of bone,
the dagger impacts,
and as it hits the grounds
and it turns to dust.
The sheer force of it
causing whatever possible
undead willpower that held it
together to just atomize.
You just hear my dagger go...
"I think that's all of them."
"That wasn't too bad."
-Technical question?
-Yes.
Since it was both of our turns
at the same time,
do I still get that
6 arcane power?
You get it back regardless
outside of the combat.
You're one of the few
that generates,
you're usually
at full arcane power
at the beginning of the fight.
The problem is,
a lot of you things cost a lot.
So what we're saying
is that by the next round
-I'll have full arcane power?
-You will.
-I didn't know that.
-Lucky.
There you go.
The fun thing about wizards.
They don't have to build up
their resources, you start full.
But you've got to be careful
what you use.
Yeah, it's meteors ****,
whatever.
-Meteors.
-Alrighty.
So, checking the body of Cresh
amongst the armor
you do find a couple of items,
because it's Diablo and that's
one of the cool parts about it.
You find a magical ring
of silver and gold inlay
and beneath its helmet
you can see this burial shawl
that seems to shimmer
in the torchlight.
The shawl is considered
The Shawl Of The Forsaken,
and it gives whoever wears it
a plus 1 to hit on any of their
abilities that rolled a hit.
The ring is
The Ring Of The Zakarum,
which gives
a plus 1 to your armor class
and saves whilst it's worn.
As the one who casted the meteor
that took out this **** here,
can I lay claim to the ring?
Sure.
Thank you,
So, AC and (indistinct)
go up by 1.
Who would like
The Shall Of The Forsaken?
-I mean.
-"I'm good, with faith."
Any one feel like they need a
little boost to their attacks?
We are good as well.
Onyx is so polite.
"What about you, Spell Slots?"
-Goes to Remy.
-You got it.
Plus 1 to hit
on all your abilities.
Sweet.
Descending the stairway beyond
this encounter with Cresh,
the air grows slightly warmer
and carries a hint
of putrescence upon it.
While the architecture remains a
continuation of the crypt above,
these walls have seen
more wear and tear.
Odd, black iron chains
dangle in places,
some of them finishing
in large metal hooks.
The recurring chair beliefs
and holy iconography you see
are often scratched out
or gauged entirely
from the walls around you.
When the steps come to an end
you can see
this much larger chamber,
maybe 100 or so feet across,
but there are 4 smaller,
almost mausoleum-like
doored chambers within.
What would you like to do?
Four...
And they're closed?
The doors are all closed?
Seems to be, yeah.
Do we hear any noise?
"Does Johnny
have any inclination
of where this child is?"
Johnny goes
"Oh yeah, across the way
this door on the other side,
that's where we're
supposed to be."
"What's behind the other doors?"
"The room
where the child is, come on."
And you see him walking ahead.
"Just let him go first,
like 15-20 feet."
"Let's see what happens"
"Also, he didn't answer
our question at all."
"No, he didn't."
We're gonna let him go
and see what happens.
He walks along,
picks up a gold piece
and put it in his sack.
Takes a few more steps,
"Oh, that's nice."
Picks up a candleholder
and puts it in the bag.
I run ahead of him
and kick any pots
that are in the way.
LAUGHTER
He's like, "No, wait!"
These pots are mostly empty.
He does rush off into one
chamber with an open door.
He goes, "Ooh,"
and darts in there.
He's easily distracted
by his particular interest
in finding worthwhile things
in the vicinity.
He rushes in.
There are the 4 chambers.
You pass the first 2.
The one on the right is open,
the one on the right is ajar.
He rushes to the left
and begins to push his way in.
You see him disappear
inside that chamber.
Are there any screams
coming from that chamber?
You don't hear any.
What about the one to the right?
To the right?
You don't hear anything
coming from that one.
You want to make
a perception check?
(GRUNTS)
Twenty.
As you glance through
and look into this open doorway,
this next room...
it's far more grotesque
than you were expecting.
You can see,
all across the floor,
there are dozens and dozens
of long-rotted corpses,
mostly skeletal,
bits of putrid flesh
still hanging on the bone.
There are many chains
hanging from this room
and bodies on hooks
all the meat has sloughed off.
This has been here
for quite some time.
It's been left still
and filled with rot.
Glancing inside
in the middle of it,
you see this squat,
tubby-looking,
red and black skinned
demonic creature
that is sitting with tiny,
scrawny legs and arms
and this very wide mid section.
It's horns are curled inwards.
It's just sitting there,
chewing on a bone.
-Does it see me?
-It does not see you.
Make a stealth check,
actually, if you don't mind.
Twelve.
It looks up at you
and darts off
into the shadow nearby.
"Friend or foe?"
There's a brief pause
and a voice rings out
from the shadow that says,
"You step into the realm of
Damershaal,
the great Eater of Storms,
Lord of Annihilation and
demon master of this dominion!"
"Leave now
or become devoured by
his immense and terrible form!"
Does he sound full of (BLEEP)?
Make an insight check.
Great. Fourteen.
It's easy to notice.
Yeah, he's full of (BLEEP).
"Do we waste our time here?"
"Are we supposed
to eradicate all of the evil?"
"I am."
I'm going to try
and drag him out
of whatever cubbyhole he's in.
Make a perception check
as you enter this chamber
filled with bones.
Not good. Four.
You look in the room. You have
no idea where this thing is.
You heard
the voice boom from it,
but you push through the chains.
The voice says, "I said
run away before it's too late!"
"Please!"
"Please."
"How long have you been here?"
"Since time eternal,
about a year."
"We're hearing
about a child here."
"Do you know
anything about that?"
Make a persuasion check.
That's much better.
Twenty-one.
Stepping out
from this cluster of bones
that have melted together
as the fats of the bodies
have solidified around it,
he pokes out at you.
This sad-looking demon creature,
maybe about 3 feet
off the ground, scutters out.
"Hi."
"I'm Damershaal,
Eater of Storms."
"Avatar form."
"Much bigger
and dangerous in true form."
"You're looking
for the child, right?"
"Seem to be."
"He's below, but the doors
are closed and locked."
"You need..."
He reaches behind the bodies
and pulls out
this stone, circular seal.
"You need this."
"So give it."
"How about we trade?"
"I'm very hungry."
"Not a lot...
around here to eat any more."
"Any fresh flesh?"
"Johnny?"
He comes out around the way
with a small box.
He's like, "I found some...
Yeah?"
Puts it in the satchel, "Yes?"
"Someone in the room
is asking for you."
He pulls a blade out.
Make a deception check.
Nine.
"What aren't you telling me?"
-"Go in the room."
-Make an intimidation check.
Come on, big money.
Seventeen?
Seventeen. He goes...
(STUTTERS)
"Of course, of course. Yeah.
Got to keep you all safe."
He creeps in
with his dagger out.
Walks into the room and sees...
the creature and goes...
"Kill it, kill it! There's
another one of them demons."
I nod and smile
at our demon friend.
"Make friends."
-"Be nice."
-"For me?"
"Don't be rude."
-The demon walks forward.
-We're terrible.
"What do you mean?"
-I close the door behind me.
-"No, no, no!"
As the door closes, you hear...
(SCREAMING)
(SNARLING)
...the screams.
And a section of the upper...
What you didn't notice
on the walls,
there are these faint,
remaining elements
of stained glass reliefs
that are on the top.
You see a bloody hand go...
(SPLAT)
...like a terrible twist
on the Titanic scene
as blood smears down the glass.
"Hey, buddy."
"What you saw back there,
that's not
how people usually act."
"We were gonna get ice cream
later. It's gonna be fine."
Spell Slots is just crying.
"It started as a joke
and then we just let it happen."
"I'm proud of us."
A few moments pass.
It grows quiet
and the door opens once more.
(SQUEAKS)
You see the squat demon come out
picking elements of muscle
from a freshly
exposed bone.
He goes, "Thank you very much.
That's a fine trade."
"Good luck with the child."
He tosses
the stone relief to you.
"I'm gonna have leftovers
for a little bit."
"Hey, do you have any use
for that bag of gold he had?"
"Could we take that?"
-"Go ahead."
-"Thank you."
"All right."
I believe Mordred
was in that room.
He walks out,
blood spattered across his face,
and says,
"That was really
something to see."
"Let's go."
All right, we go downstairs.
"We need to take care of him
on the way out, though."
-"For sure."
-"Yeah."
"Let him enjoy his last meal."
Making your way to the doors
on the opposite side,
there it is,
you can see
the large, angelic reliefs
both facing each other,
arms meeting in the center
where the circular imprint
currently awaits
the seal that you were given.
Placing it in, the doors...
open and lead you into a large,
stone, spiral staircase
that descends out of view.
"I feel so bad about Johnny."
"You're having guilt now?"
-"Too late."
-"I know it's too late."
"You want to go back and kill
him? Would you feel better?"
"No, no, it's fine."
-"Let's take care of the child."
-"Okay."
"We've got some reverse healing
to do, let's go."
Partway down the stairs,
you find an alcove
with a stone fountain of
some kind situated in the side.
The water's still running
after all this time.
As you pass by it,
a quick glance.
The waters are
red
and thicker
than the average liquid.
-Wine.
-Totally.
Can I...
touch it and feel it
with my fingers?
-Sure.
-"What's it taste like?"
-"I'm feeling it first."
-"Make sure you taste it."
"Yeah, taste it."
Somewhat viscous.
The smell is somewhat iron-like.
"What does it taste like,
though?"
"I can't believe you tasted it."
"That's gross."
(SPLUTTERING)
"It's blood. Turns out
this fountain bleeds."
"Maybe it can die."
"All right, let's go."
Continuing
down the spiral staircase...
I just like that
that's how they're bonding.
"That was pretty good."
At the base of the stairs,
you find an open,
arched threshold
that leads
into a massive shrine,
long since repurposed
as a catacomb.
The intricate walls
are lined with stone reliefs
of angels and demons
fighting mid-battle
rising tall
to the 30 foot ceiling above
where hundreds of still lit
candles fill every open pocket.
Dual curving stairs rise
against the sides of the wall
to climb to a risen platform
where a pulpit and altar sit
on top, to the back wall
far from where you look up.
The center of the room
holds a half dozen,
heavy, intricate stone tombs,
carvings of ancient warriors
carved atop the lids,
a bit scattered
in their positioning.
And the floor.
The floor shines with thousands
and thousands of gold pieces
glittering in the light between
the scattered piles of bones.
The air suddenly grows
incredibly cold,
your breath immediately visible.
The candles
all flicker in unison,
their flames shifting
from yellow-orange
to a dull blue.
Pale blue.
You see a spectral entity rise,
from the gold on the floor.
It's a child.
A boy in his teenage years,
his clothes dirty and tattered.
His left leg seems
to vanish past the knee.
As he floats above
within the room...
(ECHOING) "More imbeciles
come to help me out."
"Great."
"The bigger the network,
the easier the profit."
"You...
see this
depressingly small hoard."
"It's nowhere near enough!"
"Good help seems to always
be a challenge to find."
"You all look slightly
less useless than the others."
"You want to live?"
"Go."
"Get out there
in the western kingdoms and
bring me some real treasure."
He floats there
awaiting a response.
"I don't know about you all,
but I had no plans to go west."
"I also work for no one."
"Just make yourselves useful."
"I need gold."
-"We'll make ourselves useful."
-"Give me some."
His face pouts a little bit.
"Why is it
so hard to find help?"
"At least
Johnny's still out there."
"He'll bring me back some gold."
"I'm nowhere near close."
"What do you need it for,
young one?"
You can see the angry
frustration in the face
melt away for a second
as the spirit's eyes go distant.
"I need to help her."
"She deserves it."
"I made a promise
that I would help her
and this is
nowhere near enough."
"I can't leave
until I help her."
As that echoes
through the chamber,
you can see his spirit
flickers and grows wider.
You see the wind whip up a bit.
(BREATHES HEAVILY)
"Who is 'she'?"
"Gillian."
"Are you going
to help me or not?"
"We are going to help you
leave this mortal coil."
"Come, boy."
"Let's play."
The spirit's eyes narrow
and you watch as the chamber's
temperature drops even lower.
Blue flames flicker
in his spiritual eyes.
You watch
as all the candles begin to dim.
"If you want to walk
to your death,
that's entirely up to you,
armored boy."
"Fine."
"Let your spirit die
in some ways like mine did."
You hear the rumbling as the
bones begin to rise up and form.
You watch as these massive
skeletons begin to pull out
of the hoards of gold.
Not quite humanoid.
Larger, stranger.
Bipedal, but shouldn't be.
Large, elongated skulls
with curved horns,
not unlike the one on your head.
You see
massive, bovine-like skeletons,
holding large glaives, rise.
Two of them
to each side of this spirit.
"The cows."
"It's the cows!"
"You want to step
against the spirit of Wirt?"
"Then fine."
"Join me."
Everyone roll initiative.
So, at the top of this,
you see this spirit
of this boy, Wirt,
angrily begin to rise
and extend his hands.
You see him try
and push upwards,
it's almost like something's
pulling him down.
He gets frustrated for a second.
He's gonna go ahead
and glance...
towards you, Tauro.
And say,
"If Johnny's not gonna help, I
need someone else to help me."
"You!"
Make
a wisdom saving throw for me.
-Saving throw?
-Correct.
-Come on.
-Cocked!
Keep's getting up in...
That's real bad.
I rolled a 2.
Three total.
I think that's probably safe.
Blue flames now flicker
matchingly in the eyes of Tauro
as you become Wirt's thrall.
You are Charmed by him,
and now working
on his side for the time being.
Three cows.
"No, no. I'm not one of..."
"Good, good."
"The right attire
for the right occasion."
"Kill them, please,"
he says to the other skeletons
and continues to float up,
seemingly resisting some sort of
force that's holding him down.
Although, he's still
30 feet up in the air.
That is gonna bring us
to Indra's go.
I all of my arcane knowledge,
would I know
if physical or magical attacks
would (BLEEP) this ghost?
-Roll an arcana check.
-Okay.
-Arcana or religion, your call.
-What's 17 plus 8?
-Good enough.
-Okay, cool.
Magic of all different kinds
definitely has an impact
on spectral entities.
You would know that some
physical strikes tend to not be
as effective,
as well as cold and poison.
Seeing how they're
an undead spirit.
Good to know. Thank you.
I am going to look
at one of the moo moo men
and cast Ray of Frost at it.
All righty.
Which is... Oh, dang.
Does 15 hit?
-Fifteen does hit.
-Dope.
That is 4 D6.
Laslo, you're on deck.
-Fifteen points of cold damage.
And the target speed
is also halved.
-Nice.
-Awesome.
So one of the hell bovines
is covered in frost and ice...
crystals across it.
You can see it's having
to move and push through.
The joints are now
frozen and locked.
It's definitely slowed
and it's taken
a nice little hit to its body.
Dope. (indistinct)
Are you remaining there
in the stairway entryway?
How far am I
from everything right now?
You're about 20 feet
from the 2 skeletal bovines,
you are right next to Tauro
and the ghost is about 35 feet
within the chamber.
Seeing as Tauro is ranged,
I'm gonna stay where I am.
-I'm gonna stay put for a bit.
-You got it. Okay.
Finishing your turn,
Laslo, you're up.
Tauro, you're on deck.
The opposite
minion,
I'm going to cast Decrepify on.
Ooh, very nice.
Curse creature
within 60 feet for 4 rounds.
Their movement is halved
and any physical attacks
they use deal half damage.
It's a DC15, constitution.
Nice.
At the end of their turn.
Correct, so as you reach out,
expend the essence,
you watch as the shadows
pierce inside of it
and almost pull it
to the ground.
These tendrils of black and grey
are keeping it roped
and its bone structure
is fighting against it.
Elements of it
turning to dust by the contact.
Both of these are
pretty hindered at the moment.
Well done.
I'm going to send
Spell Slots after that guy.
Go Spell Slots!
This is gonna...
...as he's running up to him.
Ten?
Ten does not hit.
It's like a soft pillow.
More of
a gentle caress of the face.
That's the end of my turn.
Finishing Laslo's turn,
Tauro, you're up.
Your friends or your enemies?
Your choice.
Do I get to try and save from
this at the top of my turn?
-At the end of your turn.
-At the end of my turn.
Okay.
Who do I see
in my nearest periphery?
You're right next to Indra.
You are right next to
all your friends, essentially.
You guys are
still standing in the stairway.
You have the pick of the litter.
Five, 10, 15, 20.
I'm gonna roll to see.
I'm gonna attack Mordred.
Go for it.
As you're bearing down,
getting ready to charge in.
"Wait, what are you..."
"Moo (BLEEP)."
I'm going to do Hungering Arrow.
"I can't get out the way!"
Do I hit? I rolled low.
That's a GIF
if I've ever heard one.
-Moo, (BLEEP).
Can't get out the way.
Okay, the first one is a 10 to
hit, which I don't think hits.
The next one is a 15.
Miss?
-Both impact on the shield.
-Both miss.
I rolled a 9 and a 3.
Now go ahead
and roll a wisdom saving throw.
No, wait, 8 plus 9 is 17.
-No.
-Right?
Am I doing this right?
Yes I am, so 17. But still no.
-Okay, both miss.
-All right.
"Whoa! Tauro!"
Oh, no.
Things...
You're a different Tauro.
I will do my bonus action,
to spend discipline
to do Shadow Power.
So, every time I attack,
I heal myself.
You watch now as
the blue glows in Tauro's eyes.
These black, shadow wings appear
from the back,
these black tendrils
in the shape of wings
and this aura
of black energy surrounds her.
Pouring out from under the mask
and the helm.
That finishes your go, Tauro.
Go ahead and make a wisdom
saving throw for me, please.
(MUMBLING)
-You can do it. Come on.
-All right. Come on.
Big money.
Big money?
Oh my God, no. Four.
I rolled a 3.
Hell yes.
No!
That was small money.
-Small money, 4 dollars.
-Four dollars?
Oh no!
How are you supposed
to buy chicken nuggets?
Are there any pots in this room?
Just go over
and kick some pots angrily.
Finishing Tauro's turn,
the two hell bovine skeletons
begin to lurch forward
They're both slowed and can only
get to the very front line,
which means their only target
is gonna be you at the moment,
since you're the one in front.
By slowing them down,
they can't get to any of the
meatier pieces, unfortunately.
Both of them swing towards you.
They both have
the large glaives.
One of them...
To glaive.
That's a 24 to hit.
-That does kind of hit.
-Indeed.
You take...
13 points of physical damage
from the one slowed by you.
The other one,
that's gonna be a 19 to hit.
-Hits.
-Hits again.
This one, however,
is Decrepified by you.
Which means you would take 11,
reduced to 5 points
of physical damage from him.
They both also are jailers,
so you watch as...
Suddenly, I need you
to make a wisdom saving throw.
Jailers?
And you make
a wisdom saving throw.
Real low.
That is a 5.
Your movement is reduced to 0
until the end of the next turn.
I don't need movement.
-Crit fail.
-Crit fail?
Your movement
is also reduced to 0.
You're both locked into place
by some strange, arcane power
and your feet
cannot move off the ground.
Oh no.
That finishes their turn. That
brings us to Mordred and Remy.
As a bonus action,
I will recite
more scripture from the church
and use Laws of Justice
to grant myself
and allies within 30 feet
resistance to cold,
fire and lightning damage.
And I lose my action
to consecrate
the ground we stand on.
For the next 4 rounds,
we will heal.
At the start of our turns,
we get back 1 D6 plus 2.
At the start of your turns.
You've got it.
"Have pity,
they are all mooman beings."
-Oh, no.
-How long did you have that?
-How long?
-Five minutes.
Just waiting for the right time.
Finishing your go, Mordred, and
unable to move from your space,
you slam your shield
into the ground and you watch
as this arcane circle
apparates out
in a space around Mordred.
As you does,
you feel the soft, divine energy
beginning to close any wounds
as they begin to arrive.
Remy, what are you doing?
Well first,
I'm gonna heal 3 points.
-Yeah.
-There you go.
Then, I'm gonna
run up behind the bovine
that's attacking Mordred.
Actually, Mordred's probably got
it handled, I'm gonna run up
behind Laslo.
You just seem
a little bit smaller.
Both of you are actually
pretty hardcore, aren't you?
I'm pretty (BLEEP) up, actually.
I'm gonna run up behind you,
the one attacking him.
It's not gonna kill him anyway.
And I'm gonna,
as I'm running up,
turn into my crocodile form.
You got it.
-And I'm gonna Maul.
-Go for it. Maul.
Whoa, that was aggressive.
-Plus 9, so 18.
-Eighteen does hit.
All right.
-Eleven points.
-Eleven points of damage.
As you reach out, transforming,
You reach over with your claws
and bite towards him.
You take a chunk
of its bone off.
You can see part of the ribs
broken on the inside
and still holding
itself together.
Well done.
-Does that finish your go?
-Yeah.
All righty.
That now brings us to...
At the top of the ramp,
there's Wart (indistinct).
Wart is now shouting out
into the field.
"Gillian, I'm trying,
but they're getting in my way.
I'll stop you,
for her sake."
As he raises his hands
into the sky,
the wind whips up
and the ghoul begins to...
pick up in the wind,
faster and faster.
Suddenly, you're all being
pelted by a storm of gold coins.
I need everybody in the space
to go ahead and make
a dexterity saving throw
against his affluent
poltergeist stability.
What we love most
is betraying us.
-Is that including me?
-Including you.
And including the bovines.
It's everything.
No!
I got 8 doubled.
Nineteen.
Natural 20.
-Nice!
-Ooh!
Natural 6.
Twenty-three.
Is this how the pots get full?
We've figured it out.
-Success.
-We're witnessing a phenomenon.
You take what
would have been 23 points
of physical damage.
Instead, you take 11.
-Sheebus!
-What did you roll?
Natural 20 for 22.
Eleven points
of physical damage.
Six.
Twenty-three points
of physical damage.
-Wart is down.
-Oh no!
S***!
Is the ground still consecrated?
"Avenge me!"
The consecration stays.
Oh, thank goodness.
Wait, does Mordred...?
He'll heal as he...?
-At the top of--
-If it's his turn, he will.
-Uh-oh!
-Oh no!
Mess with the bull,
you get the horns.
Do I have to roll
for Spell Slots?
-Dab!
-Yes.
-Three.
-Up!
Up and away from me.
You take eleven points
of damage.
As you're shielding, you look
past the storm of gold coins.
You look out and see Spell Slots
turns around to you with...
If a skeleton
could make a sad face...
It reaches...
In that moment,
Laslo realizes...
"You've been my son
this entire time."
# Only time
The jaw gets torn off.
The arm is torn off.
Eventually,
the skeleton is pulled apart
by the pelting gold coins.
Gone.
-Twenty-three total.
-Twenty-three.
You take 11 points
of physical damage.
And make another saving throw.
-And make another saving throw.
-Correct.
Okay.
That will bring it up to 27.
Just a wisdom saving throw?
Wisdom saving throw, yeah.
-Roll to 3 again.
-Nope. Still in (indistinct).
-Alright, cool.
-Oh my God.
That finishes Wart's turn.
You can see now that
there's this angst in his face,
this deep sadness and anger,
and just, right now,
he's conflicted in this moment.
That finishes his turn.
Indra, you're up.
Laslo, you're on deck.
-So, back to the 15 feet thing?
-Yeah.
The bovines?
They are within 15 feet
of each other?
Next to each other?
They are. They both swarmed
towards Mordred, yes.
Right.
-Is it possible...?
-It might...
There's a chance
you could hit...
Remy, but...
if you wanna risk it...
I'm behind.
You're behind, okay.
Then I resend that.
Or go for it. Your call.
You know...
Nah.
(indistinct) up or down.
Oh! You said one...
I get a D6 plus... How much?
-Plus 2.
-Plus 2. All right.
Oh. Oh, 6!
And I'm going to Ray of Frost
at the same one.
Okay. Go ahead and roll again.
Sixteen plus... Twenty-six?
-Did that hit him?
-It definitely hit.
Wonderful. Now it's 5 D6.
The damage is increasing
because your focusing the beam.
Exactly.
That's 5, yeah.
That's 6.
Five, five at sixteen, plus six.
-That's twenty-two.
-Twenty-two. Twenty-four.
Twenty-four points of Chilly.
With that,
the first move
is him focusing his beam on you.
You're pushing
and focusing this intense...
arcane blast
of frozen death on to it.
As it does, the ice builds up,
builds up around it,
and it's pushing forward and
pulling its glaive into the air.
It's about to bring it down...
It freezes solid.
As the coins hit it...
it breaks away into thousands
of tiny, frozen bone fragments.
-Yeah!
-Dope, dope!
Laslo, you're up.
Do I have a clean line of...?
A clean line
to hit that other bovine?
-With a bit of movement, yes.
-Okay.
-Can I take that movement?
-Sure.
Shift to the side
and you now can see
it's between Mordred and Remy.
So, you're now hitting them
from a flailing position.
Great. I'm gonna
undo my coat real quick.
And Laslo reveals his rib cage.
It starts coming out
and twisting
into a very long spear
right at this guy.
-All right.
-I'm casting Bone Spear.
You got it.
Go ahead and... for that.
He has... the CC14.
That's right. Dexterity save.
No, natural 6.
He's not safe.
Eleven, eleven. Twenty-two.
Twenty-two points of damage?
-Yeah.
-Damn.
That's just enough, actually.
As you come out, (indistinct)...
the ribs come out and form
this spiraling drill, almost.
Magical spears blast
into the side.
You watch as it shatters
the midsection of the pelvis.
His spinal column is just gone
and the rest of it
is standing there...
hits the ground and falls apart
into pieces of bone.
Yeah, and as it goes down,
under his breath, he goes...
"You killed Spell Slots!"
That's how
origin stories start, guys.
Awesome. Finishing your turn.
Tauro, you're up.
So, okay...
Five, two, fifty, twenty.
I'll do it again.
See how I hit.
I have natural 20.
-What? Oh, now?
-Who to pick?
So...
How much hatred have you got?
-Ten hatred.
-Okay.
So, I'm gonna...
Hungering Arrow again.
Good hit. Great rolls.
Just great rolls.
-Nineteen for the first one.
-That hits.
I'll go ahead and do damage.
Great roll. 10 damage.
-Okay.
-And then 23 for the second one.
-That hits.
-That looks like it hit.
-Nine damage.
-Okay.
That's cool.
And I'm gonna spend--
We'll still be friends
if you spend this. That's fine.
I'm gonna spend 6 hatred...
to toss out
a spike trap in backup.
All right.
After you fire twice into Laslo,
suddenly, you're like, "Argh!"
You don't even see it
in the moment,
but you slip and throw a little
trap right underneath Laslo
that he does not even notice.
-Okay.
-Oh...
-So sad.
-And I'll hold.
All right.
That finishes your turn.
Both hell bovines are destroyed.
-Mordred and Remy, you're up.
-Do I get to roll? I do, right?
-To see if I save?
-You do, yes.
-Come on!
-Big money!
-Okay!
There's a 15,
plus my wizard's save
for 16 total.
You break free
of the influence of Wart.
So, I'm about to...
I back up and I'm about to hit
the detonator on the trap.
And I'm gonna go...
Perfect.
That finishes your go.
What are you guys doing?
Well, I rolled a 6 on a D6,
so I get 18 points back.
Indeed. So, you heal, come to
consciousness and look around.
Who...
The wind is still
whipping coins around you
and you can barely see
above the glowing spectral form
of this infuriated child.
"There's nothing I can do
to get up there, so I just..."
Am I still held in place
from the...?
-Bovines? Yeah.
-The bovines are dead.
-So, I can move, right?
-Indeed.
Can I use half my movement
to return to standing?
You get back up.
Then I will continue
to recite the Laws of Justice
to keep up our resistance,
because it's about all I can do.
Maybe Gillian's under the gold.
He keeps...
He keeps pointing down.
Make a history check for me.
-Ten.
-Ten?
It's hard to place, but you've
come across a Gillian before.
You can't quite pinpoint it,
though.
She did sound familiar.
Gillian Anderson of the X-Files.
-That's your turn?
-That's it, yeah.
All righty.
What are you doing, Remy?
The only thing I can try to do
is Windshear.
So, I'm gonna
hold up my arm again.
A Spectral Blade is gonna
shoot out towards the child.
You've got it.
That's a 27 to hit.
That does hit.
Three D8s.
Oh, s****.
-Seventeen... points.
-Seventeen points. Nice.
So, it does strike him.
But the Windshear doesn't impact
as heavily as you'd hope.
The spectral form
is seemingly resistant
to a lot of physical damage.
Yeah, I can only
do physical damage, guys.
Sorry about that.
So, he is still
sitting strong, angry,
and the storm
is still whipping around.
That finishes your turn.
I'm gonna...
Go with me on this.
I'm gonna send my swarm
of insects as a bonus action.
Okay.
But I'm gonna swarm them down
and under the gold.
-Okay.
-Scurrying for something...
Okay.
We'll come to you
next round, then.
Coming to the top of the round,
it's Wart's turn again.
He's gonna continue
towards the center in a frenzy.
Everyone, once again,
make a dexterity saving throw.
-Go down--
-Oh, boy!
I'm gonna go back down again.
-Hm-hmm.
-Ooh, that's bad.
Oh, actually, it might be okay.
Fifteen.
Nineteen points
of physical damage.
Is that halved?
No, she failed.
-Ooh! Fails.
-Okay.
I failed.
Nineteen points
of physical damage.
Nineteen.
You take...
nine points of physical damage.
-Mordred is down.
-Oh, Mordred!
Twenty-one.
Take nine points
of physical damage.
I failed. Fifteen, so...
Take nineteen points
of physical damage.
You're getting...
This is turning very badly.
You're getting the sense that...
on a physical feature,
combat-on-combat scenario,
you're at a severe disadvantage,
and this is already
turning against you.
That brings us to Indra.
So, I'm gonna start...
opening a tear in the universe.
Okay.
"But before I destroy
all of your treasures and gold,
because I can and I will...
what do you want us to do?"
Make a persuasion check.
Oh, I'm good at that!
Come on, come on!
Come on, Indra!
Thirteen.
Yeah.
He's, at this point,
just in this rage
and glances over towards you
and goes...
"You have already passed
the point of being helpful
by destroying my friends."
"What if
we get you more friends?"
"Just bring me gold for her.
All you can find.
She...
is too good for all of you!"
"Who's 'she'? We can't help you
if you don't tell us things."
"Gillian, obviously."
You heard Gillian earlier.
"And who is Gillian?"
-Make a history check.
-Nah.
Come on.
-Fifteen.
-Fifteen?
You did come across a Gillian
in Caldeum once.
She...
was raising a small child.
-This is a few years ago.
-Oh, no. Mommy.
She was raising a small child.
The tear won't close,
but Indra lowers her staff.
"Is that your mom?"
"No!
Not my mom!"
"Sorry for assuming!"
That ends your turn.
He is not happy about that.
Oh, God!
What are you doing, Laslo?
How far up is he?
About 30 feet from you. 35 feet.
Oh!
-Too far.
-Move to get closer if you want.
Even...
Yeah, if he's floating, I want
to cast Death Nova again...
the poison,
but it's 20 feet from me?
Yeah, it's not gonna reach him.
If my hair's really high,
will it hook...?
-Not quite.
-Jump up in the air.
Yeah, then...
I'm gonna try to...
There's nothing I can do.
This is all physical.
I might Bone Spear him.
-Okay.
-Yeah.
Go for it. All right, so he...
Dexterity save.
Does not save.
Go ahead and roll again.
So, that's a nine plus...
nine.
-Eighteen.
-Eighteen. All right.
The spear strikes him.
Once again, the spectral form
shimmers as it hits,
but as a physical damage source,
it's not doing
quite as much as you want.
-Does that finish your turn?
-That finishes it.
-Tauro, you're up.
-Okay.
I'm going to use my discipline
to cast Marked for Death on him.
-Okay.
-And then...
That brings it back down to 13.
-And then, I'm going to spend...
-Mordred, (indistinct).
Spend 12 hatred
to do Rapid Fire.
So, that brings me down
to 3 hatred. Okay.
All right. So, 6 attacks at him.
Go for it.
All plus 5 to hit,
so first attack
is a natural 18, so 23.
That hits.
-Shall I do these one at a time?
-Roll your attacks upfront.
-Okay.
-One hit.
That hits.
Ooh, that's not as good.
-That is a 13.
-Misses.
-That's even worse.
-Fifteen.
-Misses.
Oh my God.
-Is this attack four?
-This is the fifth attack now.
-Oh my God. A natural one.
-Misses. Last attack.
Okay. And... a 13, so 18 total.
-Yeah, so 2 hits.
-Oh! Yikes.
Another 6. Okay.
Two D6 on this one, plus two.
Okay.
So, that is...
8 damage on the first one.
Okay.
And... 12 damage on the second.
-Okay. So, 20 damage halved--
-Twenty damage total.
Physical damage
not quite impacting heavily
on the spiritual entity.
Okay.
This is not looking good.
That finishes your turn, Tauro.
Mordred, Remy, you're up.
Okay. Mordred comes to again.
How are you doing?
As a bonus action, I will do
Laws of Justice for everybody,
but then I will say,
"Come, child.
Perhaps we can leave
this place together."
And I will provoke him.
Okay.
So, he has to make it easy.
Wisdom of 14.
Natural one.
-So, he's gonna come for me.
-Yes, he does.
And I'll just stay
on the ground, smiling up.
Okay.
Remy, what are you doing?
I'm gonna say, "Gillian?
I've heard of a Gillian."
Make a persuasion check.
-Big money.
-With advantage, using the name.
Oh. Okay.
Okay...
Seventeen.
You watch as the anger
and frustration
in the middle of this child's
face goes...
"You two...
Where?
How?
Where is she?"
The coins begin
to slow down and...
fall around.
"Calm down and we can tell you."
Looking back at Mordred...
The coins begin
to slow even further,
and you're no longer
being pelted
like in the middle
of a terrible storm,
and more
just a gentle battering.
As the spirit glides down,
the candles
flicker brighter once more
and float there.
The once extremely intense
and angry, wrathful spirit
now looks more age appropriate.
This...
child entity
looks at you with
this snot-nosed, mid-teens face
and goes...
"What...?
How...?"
"How did you
get taken from her?"
"All of us did here.
And they
destroyed the town, but...
she got away in time, I think.
I wasn't ready.
The project wasn't ready.
I was saving. It's not enough.
I have to keep saving,
make sure she's okay.
"Child.
We can take you to her.
This is more gold
than she could ever want."
"I can't save...
myself from this.
I can't leave.
Not until I have enough.
She's...
She's worth all of this."
Roll the nature check for me,
if you would, Mordred.
Oh, very nice. 20.
Often, wrathful spirits
that are left behind
are bound
by unfinished business...
or the thought
of unfinished business,
or something
is binding them there.
You're not certain
how sincere he is,
but based on the words
that he's saying,
he does not feel he can leave.
"How much gold
do you think you have here?"
"13,261...
not including
what you brought here.
"And what were you
trying to build for her?"
"A future.
Tristram
couldn't provide for her.
I was planning to take her
with me when I got away.
I know
she's a little older, but...
I'd grow up eventually."
"You were in love with her."
"No!
I just wanted
to make sure she was okay."
"Can we look in on her for you?"
Make a persuasion check.
Twenty-one.
"Would you do that?
Would you bring her this?"
He gestures to the gold
in the chamber.
"If it will bring rest to you
in this place."
The spirit glides to the ground,
floating just inches above it.
It mimics sitting on the edge
of one of the tombs,
and this wrathful spirit,
more than you've noticed
at this point, just looks...
pitiful.
"We're hoping to...
rid Tristram
of this pain and suffering...
and rebuild.
This could go a long way
towards that life.
A happy life for Gillian."
"I don't care
about Tristram anymore.
This place is ruined.
Too much evil has happened here
and it's just gonna
keep getting worse.
But if you think--"
"Tristram Smishstram.
This gold's for Gillian.
We'll take it to Gillian."
"Okay.
Okay."
And with that, you see
the spirit begin to fade
and drift into the ground.
All the rest of the gold...
Ting! Ting!
...falls around the stone.
And it's hard to explain, but
in that moment, if feels like...
a tension.
A thickness in the air
seems to lighten.
And with that,
you begin to gather the coins
and the treasure
and all the valuables that
have been gathered over time
by whatever grave robbers...
and tomb raiders and such that
have found their way into...
the sub
cathedral region.
I couldn't dig under
where he was perched
at the top of the mound.
Is there anything of importance
under there...
as to why he was there?
Yeah, swarm full of bugs.
Oh God!
-Oh!
-True.
What you do find is...
a small locket...
with...
a drawing.
Not a very well-done drawing,
but it looks to be a woman.
Okay.
Young. Dark hair.
I show it to Indra and Remy.
"Does this look like
the Gillian you remember?"
"I... I just recognize her name.
I really don't have any idea."
Does it?
It does. It's poorly drawn.
-Yeah.
-It can kind of pass.
It's like
a Ramona Flowers drawing?
-Yeah.
-Yeah, straight up.
Put it over my...
neck.
"Alright, I guess
we're gonna be messengers."
Mordred shoves an empty pot
into Laslo's hands.
"Hold this."
"One..."
For the hours it takes to gather
this treasure that's left here,
you finally have the last
gold piece in your grasp.
And as you begin to exit
up the staircase,
the voice once more creeps in...
"She gets every coin.
Or I'll follow you
for the rest of my days.
I'm not above being
a little s*** for eternity."
And that's where
we'll end this session.
You'll have
to follow us to Vegas
because
we're getting f****** up!
We go straight to a priest.
We all get exorcised.
LAUGHTER
We take all the gold.
Historically, it goes over
really well
in the land of Sanctuary.
Oh, yeah!
-We're friends, you know?
-That's sweet. Yeah.
-Great.
-Justice for Spell Slots!
Yeah, none of you guys...
None of you guys showed up
for Spell Slots's funeral.
"We already buried him once."
What can I say
about Spell Slots?
He was the best among us.
He was a dirty little Kanye fan,
but we loved him all the same.
I bury him like this...
He is next to his face.
Thank you, guys, for
joining me into this rapid...
Yay!
...dungeon delve
in Diablo.
We ran a little over. Thank you
for your patience, everyone.
Thank you all for watching.
We hope you enjoyed it
as much as we did.
Being ridiculous and dark
and silly and fun
and killing monsters...
-And grave robbers.
You can hit the gammon today.
It worked out well.
If you wanna rewatch
this campaign
or check out any of
the other amazing free content,
as part of BlizzConline,
visit BlizzConline.com.
Thank you for having us.
We love you very much.
-We'll get that treasure goblin!
-Good night.
LAUGHTER
# PIANO MUSIC
J. ALLEN BRACK: Games are
here for us during good times,
and they're here for us
even when we feel alone.
They give us experiences
that are relevant
to the times in our lives,
and experiences
that we carry forward with us.
You know, online worlds have
been a huge part of our lives
for decades now.
The world has thrown a lot at us
since the last BlizzCon,
and the thing that's really kept
everyone going on the WoW team
has been connecting
with all of you.
And on behalf of all of us
at Hearthstone,
we want to thank
the many millions of you
who play our game.
Your dedication and support
is what drives us
to make awesome updates
and pursue ambitious
and fun ideas.
LUIS BARRIGA:
And I am honored to be here
on behalf of all
of our Diablo teams.
And I hope you'll agree with me
that it's a great time to be
a member of this community.
JEFF KAPLAN: The thing
that I'm most excited about
is that moment when we hand
the game over to the players.
That's why we do it.
We create the game
because we want it to become
part of your life,
and for you to experience it.
SARALYN SMITH: That concludes
our first ever BlizzConline.
We've had
millions of players tune in
from all corners of the planet,
lots of reactions to our games,
and love shared
for our incredibly talented,
motivated,
and generous community.
We are all united
by love of gaming,
and at this time in humanity,
finding what connects us,
and human connection in general,
can be a light
during darker moments.
For many of us,
BlizzCon is a light.
Yes, we love seeing Blizzard's
latest announcements revealed,
but it's even more than that.
It's connection,
inclusion,
a reminder to proudly embrace
our inner geek,
and that there are
so many people out there
creating and playing
in these fantastical worlds.
These past two days, we came
together for BlizzConline,
from our studio shoot
of Opening Ceremony
with epic Blizzard cinematics,
to hearing from the folks that
dreamt up Blizzard 30 years ago.
Those early days were so pure
and so simple.
Let's just make games
and have some fun.
We brought back
BlizzCon headliners,
like Metallica
and Lindsey Stirling...
visited with our ever-amazing
voice actors...
Be blessed, be well,
be happy, be healthy.
But most importantly, be you.
Just know that you...
you are all so beautiful.
When things seem the darkest,
the light is always with you.
...watched fun competitions,
like the battles from StarCraft
Legends, held in Korea.
And congrats to our
Community Showcase winners.
I am so thrilled
pet cosplay seems like it's
a thing that's here to stay.
I am thrilled
to be back with you!
Thrilled!
Do you hear me saying this?
Thank you, thank you,
thank you, all,
for sharing your time with us.
Wherever you are watching from,
I hope that you and yours
are safe and healthy.
SARALYN: The spirit of BlizzCon
has a special place
in our hearts,
largely thanks to all of you
and how you have shown up for us
over the years,
whether that's
dressed as a Murloc
or in Tracer cosplay,
with your guild, your partner,
family or friends.
Thank you.
Happy 30 years, Blizzard,
and thanks to all of you
for joining us.
We hope to see you again soon.